Bumble knows it's hard to start conversations. Hey, no, too basic. Hi there. Still no. What about hello, handsome? Ugh, who knew you could give yourself the ick? That's why Bumble is changing how you start conversations. You can now make the first move or not.
Bumble 知道开启对话很难。嘿，不，太基础了。嗨。还是不对。帅哥，你好怎么样？天哪，谁知道你还能让自己感到恶心？这就是为什么 Bumble 正在改变你们开启对话的方式。你现在可以主动出击，或者不。
With opening moves, you simply choose a question to be automatically sent to your matches. Then sit back and let your matches start the chat. Download Bumble and try it for yourself. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
通过开场白，你只需选择一个问题，系统就会自动发送给与你匹配的人。然后坐下来，让你的配对对象发起聊天。下载 Bumble 并亲自试试吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
现在，我们专门为你带来了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是专门为你打造的终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是专门为你打造的终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享独家的幕后
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi everybody. It is AARM part two. You know what that means. Next week is the finale. Yeah.
只有亲历现场的两个人才能讲给你的故事。我们是专门为你打造的终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是专门为你打造的终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是专门为你打造的终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。你好。大家好。这是《AARM》第二部分。你知道这意味着什么。下周就是大结局了。耶。
Wow. This is season nine, episode 25, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Dave Rogers. And here's your summary. Newly convinced that Philip is his son, Dwight unromantically proposes marriage to Angela. She says no. With the help of the documentary crew, Jim reassures Pam that she is more than enough for him. Daryl's coworkers make one last request before he leaves.
哇。这是第九季第 25 集，由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯导演。以下是剧情摘要：德怀特新近确认为菲利普是他的儿子，于是很不浪漫地向安吉拉求婚。她拒绝了。在纪录片摄制组的帮助下，吉姆向帕姆保证，对于他而言，她早已足够好。达里尔的同事在他离开前提出了最后一个请求。
Andy's singing dreams are shattered by Clay Aiken. And Dwight proposes again romantically to Angela and she says, yes, nothing says romance like a bullhorn. That's one of my favorite parts of that scene. Well, everyone, I am holding my pockets mug again, but it's not because I have a soap box today. It is because we have found Katie! Katie, the maker of the pockets mug and the hummingbird mug!
安迪的歌唱梦想被克莱·艾肯击碎。德怀特又浪漫地向安吉拉求婚了，她答应了，没有什么比一个扩音器更能诠释浪漫了。那是那一幕中我最喜欢的片段之一。好吧，各位，我又拿着我的口袋马克杯了，但今天不是因为我有长篇大论要发表。而是因为我们找到凯蒂了！口袋马克杯和蜂鸟马克杯的制作者凯蒂！
Which I am holding right now as well. Kaya Goodwin from South Carolina went full mom detective, although she actually solved this case. So, slightly mom detective. Yes. She found Katie and Cassie was able to get in touch with her. And everybody, Katie has an Etsy store for her pottery. It's so beautiful. Katie, you are so talented. Jenna and I have already picked a few things we want to buy.
我现在手里也正拿着呢。来自南卡罗来纳州的卡亚·古德温化身全职妈妈侦探，虽然实际上是她破了案。所以，勉强算个妈妈侦探吧。是的。她找到了凯蒂，卡茜也得以与她取得联系。大家注意，凯蒂在 Etsy 上开了一家陶艺店。太漂亮了。凯蒂，你太有才了。我和珍娜已经挑了几件想买的东西。
It's true. We told Katie we would share about her Etsy shop. Now, I believe she's willing to make more pocket mugs, but please be kind to her because she is just one gal making amazing pottery. So we don't want to overwhelm her. With pocket mugs and hummingbird mugs, you have to be patient.
千真万确。我们告诉凯蒂我们会分享她的 Etsy 店铺。现在，我相信她愿意制作更多的口袋马克杯，但请大家对她好一点，因为她只是一个制作精美陶艺的姑娘。所以我们不想给她压垮。对于口袋马克杯和蜂鸟马克杯，你必须有耐心。
She makes everything herself. Yes. Her Etsy shop is called Ravens and Widow and we will link to it in our stories. We sure will. Cheers lady. Cheers. Alright so here we go, fast fact number one. Let's talk about the next acapella sensation celebrity judges. Aaron Rodgers, Clay Aiken, and Santi Gold. Can you believe it? We got these three? Amazing.
她所有东西都是自己亲手做的。是的。她的 Etsy 店铺叫 Ravens and Widow，我们会在快拍中放上链接。我们一定会的。干杯，女士。干杯。好了，我们开始吧，趣味冷知识一号。来聊聊下一位无伴奏合唱轰动事件的明星评委吧。亚伦·罗杰斯、克莱·艾肯和桑蒂·戈德。你能相信吗？我们请到了这三位？太棒了。
So when we got the script for this, when we did the table read, there were just placeholders. It was like pop star, country star, and athlete. And we found Santi Gold and Clay Aiken through Alison Jones. But our own Brian Baumgartner is how we got Aaron Rodgers. That's true. Because he had met Aaron at like a celebrity golf tournament or something.
所以当我们拿到这个剧本时，当我们进行剧本围读时，上面只有占位符。比如流行巨星、乡村巨星和运动员。我们通过艾莉森·琼斯找到了桑蒂·戈德和克莱·艾肯。但我们能请到亚伦·罗杰斯全靠我们自己的布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。确实如此。因为他在某个名人高尔夫锦标赛之类的活动上遇到了亚伦。
Yeah. And Aaron Rogers was a huge fan of the office. Like super fans. Super fan. He even came to set one time. Remember when we were filming and he wanted to take pictures with all of us? Yes. So after the table read, Brian went to Greg and the producers and was like,
是的。而且亚伦·罗杰斯是《办公室》的超级粉丝。就像超级粉丝那种。超级粉丝。他甚至有一次还来到了片场。还记得我们在拍摄时，他想跟我们所有人都合影吗？是的。所以在剧本围读后，布莱恩去找了格雷格和制片人们，然后说，
hey, how about athlete is Aaron Rodgers? I mean, he would flip out to do this. And that is how we got Aaron Rodgers, who, by the way, had just recently led the Green Bay Packers to victory in the Super Bowl and was the Super Bowl and NFL season MVP for that season. Yeah. You know, I have a little bit of an embarrassing story of when I first met Aaron. Okay.
嘿，让运动员由亚伦·罗杰斯来演怎么样？我的意思是，他做这个一定会兴奋疯的。这就是我们如何请到亚伦·罗杰斯的，顺便说一句，他当时刚刚带领绿湾包装工队在超级碗中取得胜利，并且是那一季超级碗和 NFL 赛季的常规赛 MVP。是的。你知道吗，当我第一次见到亚伦时，我有一个稍微有点尴尬的故事。好吧。
So Brian had done the golf tournament with him. Yeah. And they became friends. And I don't know if it was like a few weeks later or what, but Brian texted me and was like, Hey, my friends in town, we're gonna go have dinner. Do you want to join us? I'm gonna get a group of people together for dinner. I was like, Sure, sounds great. All I knew was his friend played sports.
所以布莱恩曾和他一起参加过高尔夫锦标赛。是的。然后他们成了朋友。我不知道是几周后还是什么时候，布莱恩给我发短信说，嘿，我的朋友在城里，我们要去吃晚饭。你想加入我们吗？我要把一帮人聚在一起吃晚饭。我说，当然，听起来不错。我只知道他的朋友从事体育运动。
Right? That's it. Brian didn't say anything else in the text. So I go to this dinner and man, oh man, am I noticing people, like, from every walk of life tripping over themselves to say hi to Brian's friend. And I'm sitting next to him at dinner, and we're talking about work and stuff, and I go, so you play football? And he said, I do. And I said, that's so fun.
对吧？就这样。布莱恩在短信里没说别的。所以我去了那个晚宴，天哪，天哪，我注意到各行各业的人都在争先恐后地跟布莱恩的朋友打招呼。我坐在他旁边吃晚饭，我们聊了工作之类的事情，我说，所以你踢美式橄榄球？他说，是的。我说，太有趣了。
That's really cool. And I was like, what position do you play? He said, I'm a quarterback. And I go, wow! That's like big time. And then we don't really talk any more about it, you know? We just talk about all kinds of other stuff. And this is when I had just started dating Josh. And the next day, he and I are on the phone. And he was like, how was your dinner with Brian and his friends? I said, so fun. I met such a nice guy. He's a quarterback for, I think, Seattle. Something with a bird, maybe a hawk. He goes, what's his name? I said, Aaron. He goes, no, no, no. There's no quarterback named
真的很酷。然后我问，你踢什么位置？他说，我是四分卫。我说，哇！那可是大人物啊。然后我们真的没再多聊这个了，你知道吗？我们只是聊了各种各样别的事。正是在这个时候，我刚开始和乔许约会。第二天，我和他在电话里聊天。他说，你和布莱恩及他朋友们的晚宴怎么样？我说，太有趣了。我遇到一个很好的人。他是某个队的四分卫，我想是西雅图。名字里带个鸟，可能是鹰。他说，他叫什么名字？我说，亚伦。他说，不，不，不。没有一个四分卫叫
Aaron for Seattle. He goes, I go, well, I think he's a pretty big deal because people were really excited to meet him. Then he goes, is it Aaron Rodgers, Ange? And I said, yes, that's it. And he goes, oh my God, that's crazy. He went dinner with him. He had no idea. He was just so nice and just unassuming. And anyway, I didn't know he was the quarterback for a Green Bay. Well, I have a really fun audio clip for later in the episode because there was somebody else who also did not know who he was when they met him on our set that day. Oh, yeah.
亚伦在西雅图。他说，我说道，好吧，我觉得他是个挺大的人物，因为大家见到他都很兴奋。然后他说，是亚伦·罗杰斯吗，安吉？我说，是的，就是他。然后他说，天哪，太疯狂了。你跟他一起吃了晚饭。她完全不知道。他就是那么好，那么谦逊。总之，我不知道他是绿湾的四分卫。嗯，我有一段非常有趣的音频剪辑要在本集稍后播放，因为还有另一个人，当那天在片场遇到他时，也不知道他是谁。哦，是的。
I'll save it. But it made me chuckle. Well, I'm a huge football fan, a football person, and I remember when he came to set and I was just so tickled that he was so excited to take a picture with me. Yeah. You know, because I was like, you're Aaron Rodgers. Oh, there were so many fantasy football teams on our show. The whole set was so excited to have him visit. It's very true. Well, I'm excited to talk about another big guest star from this episode. It's our fast fact number two, and it is Santi Gold.
我先留着不说。但那让我咯咯笑了起来。好吧，我是个超级橄榄球迷，一个橄榄球迷，我还记得他来到片场时，他那么兴奋地想跟我合影，这让我感到非常高兴。是的。你知道的，因为我觉得，你可是亚伦·罗杰斯。哦，我们剧组有那么多的梦幻橄榄球球队。整个片场都为他的来访感到无比兴奋。确实如此。好吧，我很高兴能聊聊本集的另一位大牌客串明星。这是我们的趣味冷知识二号，她就是桑蒂·戈德。
Angela, we have a story about her. We were at a benefit fundraiser where she was performing. Yes, we got pretty excited. This is recently. This is a long time since she's been on the show. Yeah, this was just a few years ago, you guys. It was. First of all, I'll say we were right at the front.
安吉拉，我们有一个关于她的故事。我们在一个她有演出的慈善募捐活动上。是的，我们当时相当兴奋。这是最近的事。离她上节目已经过去很长时间了。是的，各位，这只是几年前的事。确实是。首先，我要说，我们就站在最前面。
We were right at the lip of the stage. We were dancing hardcore. Yeah, we were. She was playing creator, my favorite song. And can we have it, by the way? Could we listen to some of that? Oh my gosh, yes. Can we?
我们就站在舞台边缘。我们疯狂地跳舞。是的，我们确实跳了。她当时在演奏《Creator》，我最喜欢的歌。顺便问一句，我们能放一下吗？我们可以听听其中的一部分吗？哦天哪，可以。可以吗？
Can we play a little bit of it? I'd like to. Because I want like to. Because I want you to understand this is what Angela and I are rocking out to at like the front of this performance. The very front of the stage. Yes. Got no need for the fancy things All the attention that it brings
我们能放一小段吗？我想听。因为我想让你明白，这就是我和安吉拉在这场演出最前方疯狂摇摆的样子。舞台的最前方。是的。无需那些浮华的事物 以及它带来的所有关注
Tell me no I say yes I chosen. And I will deliver the explosion. Can't say it's gonna get me far. Do no good to say what you are. I run the streets and I break up houses. River runs deep and the flame devours it. Okay, so that is one of my songs I listen to when I wanna feel like a badass boss lady. That's right. So we are two badass boss lady. That's right.
告诉我不要 我说好 我是被选中的。我会制造爆炸。不能说这会让我走得远。说出你是谁也无济于事。我在街头奔跑，我拆散家庭。河流奔腾深邃，烈焰将其吞噬。好的，这就是我想要感觉像个不好惹的女老板时会听的歌之一。没错。所以我们是两个不好惹的女老板。没错。
So we are two badass boss ladies. We are rocking out at the foot of the stage and she says, everybody come up, come up, come on stage and dance with me. We're like, we will. We're like, heck yeah. We start to mount the stage and a big beefy guy, he was a bouncer. Like a bouncer person. Yeah, who worked at the venue was like,
所以我们是两个不好惹的女老板。我们在舞台脚下疯狂摇摆，她说，大家上来，上来，上台来和我一起跳舞。我们心想，我们会上去的。我们想，太棒了。我们开始往舞台上爬，一个身材魁梧的家伙，他是个保镖。就像一个保镖那样的人。是的，在场地工作的那个人说，
you will not be going on stage. And she was like, you are come on up on stage. We're like, she's saying we can go. And he's like, I'm saying you cannot. We almost got thrown out. I mean, one or two gals made it up on stage. We didn't. I was jealous. He pretty much like just gently picked me up and set me on the ground. He shut it down pretty quickly. But he was like, I will ask you ladies to leave if you do not stop trying to climb on the stage. I was like, oh no, we don't want to get thrown out.
你们不能上台。她却说：你们上来吧，上台来。我们心想：她说了我们可以上去。而他说：我说你们不行。我们差点被赶出去。我是说，有一两个姑娘成功上了台。我们没有。我很嫉妒。他几乎就像是轻轻把我抱起来，然后把我放在了地上。他很快就制止了这一切。但他说过：如果你们不停止试图爬上舞台，我会请女士们离开的。我当时想，哦不，我们可不想被赶出去。
We don't want to get thrown out. Also you guys, we were totally sober. We were, we were just really excited. She said, come up on stage. She did. But I know Santi and she's an amazing person. And I traded text messages with her. And she said that she would send in audio clips
我们可不想被赶出去。另外，各位，我们完全是清醒的。我们是的，我们只是真的太兴奋了。她说：上台来。她确实这么说了。但我认识桑蒂，她是个很棒的人。我和她互发了短信。她说她会发来音频剪辑
for this episode. Here's the first one. She's going to tell us how she got her job on the office. Oh, my god. I just watched the link that you sent me. It's so funny. He's so great. So yeah, I was a huge fan of The Office.
为了这一集。这是第一个。她会告诉我们她是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的。哦，天哪。我刚刚看了你发给我的链接。太搞笑了。他太棒了。所以，是的，我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。
From the beginning of The Office, I was a fan of The Office when it was just the UK version of The Office. And then when it turned to the US version, I remember it was so different. But yet, I don't want to say funnier, but it kind of was. It was just so good. And so from the very beginning I was watching it and I had seen pretty much every episode. So what happened was I, it was like, I had been touring
从《办公室》一开始，我就成了《办公室》的粉丝，当时还只是英国版的《办公室》。后来当它变成美国版时，我记得它是那么的不同。但同时，我不想说它更搞笑，但它确实有点那样。它是如此之好。所以从一开始我一直在看，几乎每一集我都看过了。所以发生的事情是，我，就像是，我一直在巡演
for quite a while and, and I wanted to do something just that seemed fresh and knew something that I didn't know how to do and that seemed fun. So I started taking some acting classes and I went on, I think it was my very first audition was for Anchorman 2. And I went and the casting agent, she said that I did really, really well and she really liked me.
好长一段时间，我想做点感觉清新、新颖的事情，做一些我不知道该怎么做而且看起来很有趣的事情。所以我开始上一些表演课，我去了，我想我的第一次试镜是为《王牌播音员2》。我去了，选角经纪人说我表现得真的非常好，她真的很喜欢我。
And then she was like, but because I had never acted before, the director wanted to go with someone who had more experience. So, you know, so I didn't get that, but she was like really nice. So she called me very shortly after and she's like, but would you want to come on The Office? And I couldn't believe it. I was like, that was like my dream. Like it, cause I just really wanted to be on something funny. Like I don't think I even really wanted to ever be an actor. I just wanted to be on something funny. And The Office was like my number one wish list. So yeah. So, so, and I get to come on and just play myself. And so that's how that happened. And I was so excited about it was like a dream come true.
然后她说，但因为我以前从未演过戏，导演想找一个更有经验的人。所以，你知道，所以我就没得到那个角色，但她人真的很好。所以不久后她给我打电话说：“不过你想不想来《办公室》客串？”我简直不敢相信。我当时想，那就像是我的梦想。就像是，因为我只是真的很想参演一些有趣的东西。我觉得我甚至可能从来都不真的想当演员。我只是想参演一些有趣的东西。而《办公室》就像是我的头号愿望清单。所以，是的。所以，所以，我得以客串并只需扮演我自己。事情就是这样发生的。我对此感到非常兴奋，这就像梦想成真一样。
Ah, so fun. Well, Dave said that she was super sweet and very talented. Dave also said she was so friendly and really warm. But then when the camera started rolling, she had to just switch into just like pissed off. And he said it was a really funny thing to watch her have to do that. I can relate. Well, I have more audio clips from Santi that I'll play later in the episode. But now Angela, it's over to you for Fast Fact 3. Yes.
啊，太有趣了。嗯，戴夫说她超级甜美，非常有才华。戴夫还说她非常友好，非常热情。但当摄像机开始转动时，她不得不立刻切换到那种生气的状态。他说看她不得不这样做是一件非常有趣的事。我能感同身受。好吧，我还有来自桑蒂的更多音频剪辑，我会在本集稍后播放。但现在安吉拉，时间交给你来公布趣味冷知识 3。是的。
Okay. So you guys know that I have been watching The Office of Lookback. It's the bonus feature on Disc Four, Season Nine. I have some more to share from it. I am titling this first part, Feeling All the Feels. Okay. Here's the cast talking about the show. Very cheesy music, just wow.
好的。所以大家知道我一直在看《办公室》回顾。那是第九季第四盘光盘上的花絮。我还有一些内容要从中分享。我给第一部分起名为：《百感交集》。好的。这是演员们在谈论这部剧。非常俗气的音乐，简直绝了。
Mm-hmm. ["Feeling All the Feels"] We knew we were a part of something different and new, which was always thrilling. I can't think of another thing that I've done for this long that is so important to me. I was on the set for this finale and I was looking around and I was just struck by the fact that there's no way you could assemble this type of cast again. It was just my absolute pleasure to be a part of the show. I'm really proud of what we did. I've been waiting here for 45 minutes.
嗯哼。[《百感交集》] 我们知道我们是某个不同且崭新事物的一部分，这总是让人激动。我想不出我做过这么久且对我如此重要的另一件事。我参加了这个大结局的片场拍摄，我环顾四周，只是被这样一个事实震撼了：你绝对不可能再聚齐这样一群演员了。能成为这部剧的一部分绝对是我的荣幸。我为我们所做的一切感到骄傲。我在这里等了 45分钟了。
And the people are amazing. What's great about the show that in its heart is an optimistic show. And I think that that is its legacy. Oh my gosh, Angela, I was trying to eat a snack while you played that clip and then I got choked up. I couldn't swallow. I watched it all happen. It's pretty emotional to watch this.
而且大家都很棒。这部剧最棒的地方在于，它本质上是一部乐观的剧。我认为这就是它的传承。哦天哪，安吉拉，我刚才在你播放那个片段时正想吃点零食，然后我就哽咽了。我咽不下去了。我都看到这一切发生了。看这个真的很感人。
Okay, and then I wanted to share a second part which is just us reflecting on will it hold up? And then also sharing the fact that we were entering those weeks where it was like our last table read, our last hot snack, our last time in hair and makeup, and it was really hitting us all. I hope it holds up. You know, I turn on Nick at Night and I see Roseanne, or I see Everybody Loves Raymond. They're great.
好的，然后我想分享第二部分，这只是我们反思它能否经得起时间的考验？还有分享这样一个事实，即我们正在进入那些周，就像我们的最后一次剧本围读，我们的最后一份热乎小吃，我们在发型和化妆间的最后一次时光，这一切真的深深触动了我们所有人。我希望它能经得起时间考验。你知道，我打开 Nick at Night 频道，我看到了罗珊，或者我看到了《人人都爱雷蒙德》。它们都很棒。
Seinfeld holds up. Years later, you watch these shows and they still make you laugh. And I just hope we're one of those shows. I don't think anybody thought we would go over 200 episodes. It is very emotional right now on the set. Everything is the last something. And I have one more thing to share. It's from my digital clutter.
《宋飞传》经受住了时间的考验。多年后，你看这些剧集，它们依然能让你开怀大笑。我只希望我们也是其中之一。我想没人会想到我们能拍到 200 集以上。片场现在情绪非常激动。每件事都是最后一次的某某。我还有一件事要分享。来自我的数字杂物堆。
It's dated May 10, 2013, which was after this episode aired. And it's from Dave Rogers. Hey, gang. I just wanted to thank everyone again for really kicking ass and doing what you do to make AARM such a truly special episode. I could not be happier or more proud of what we accomplished, and I am thrilled with the amazing feedback we've been getting from fans and critics alike. I am so honored to have earned the opportunity and trust to direct and edit such a pinnacle episode. Greg, Claire, and I are deep into the finale and I can tell you that that too will be an unbelievably spectacular sendoff for one of the greatest television shows of all time. See you soon, Dave.
日期是 2013 年 5 月 10 日，也就是本集播出之后。来自戴夫·罗杰斯。嘿，各位。我只是想再次感谢大家真正全力以赴，做你们该做的事，让《AARM》成为一个真正特别的剧集。对于我们所取得的成就，我再高兴不过了，也再骄傲不过了，我对粉丝和评论家们给予的惊人反馈感到非常激动。我很荣幸能够赢得这个机会和信任，去导演和剪辑这样一部巅峰之集的剧集。格雷格、克莱和我正在深入制作大结局，我可以告诉你，对于史上最伟大的电视剧之一来说，那也将是一场无与伦比的壮观告别。回头见，戴夫。
Oh, that's really sweet. You know, in that first clip, I guess I said something about how I didn't think I had been involved in something for so long that had such an impact on my life or something like that. Yeah. And I remember thinking that I remember thinking like how my memory of high school or my memory of college, those years are like, were so influential on my life and were so formative and the office was both of those combined together. Yeah. Like that's how much time we spent there. Yeah, a lot of life happened. Mm-hmm. Well that was Fast Fact 3. I'll be sharing more next week. Okay. So get your tissues ready for next week, lady. Okay.
哦，那真的很甜美。你知道，在那个第一个片段里，我想我提到过一些关于我不认为自己曾参与过这么长时间且对我的生活产生如此大影响的事情之类的话。是的。我记得我当时在想，我记得我当时在想，我对高中或大学的记忆，那些岁月对我的生活是多么具有影响力，塑造了我是谁，而《办公室》就是这两者的结合。是的。我们花了那么多时间在那里。是的，经历了很多生活。嗯哼。那是趣味冷知识 3。我下周会分享更多。好的。所以请各位女士为下周准备好纸巾。好的。
I'm not ready for next week. I know. I'm not either. I'm not. Well, why don't we take a break and we'll be back to Breakdown AARM Part 2. Part 2. For the past three seasons of Gone South, we've covered one story per season. We tried to figure out who killed Margaret Coon. She told me I'm gonna kill you.
我还没准备好迎接下周。我知道。我也没准备好。我还没呢。嗯，我们为什么不休息一下，然后回来剖析《AARM》第二部分。第二部分。在过去三季的《深入南方》中，我们每季报道一个故事。我们试图弄清楚是谁杀害了玛格丽特·库恩。她对我说我要杀了你。
I said, well, do it, bitch. Go ahead and do it. We delved into the violent world of the Dixie Mafia. I'm an outlaw and I was a thief, but I'm far from being the psychotic nutcase that I've been made out to be. And we tracked a serial killer in Laredo, Texas. Just turn around, please. Turn around. Now, Gone South is back for a fourth season, but this time we're doing things a little differently. for a fourth season. But this time, we're doing things a little differently.
我说，好啊，有本事杀啊，碧池。尽管来吧。我们深入探讨了迪克西黑手党的暴力世界。我是个逃犯，我曾是个小偷，但我远不是那种被妖魔化了的精神病疯子。我们在德克萨斯州拉雷多追踪了一名连环杀手。请转过身来。转过身。现在，《深入南方》第四季回归了，但这一次我们做了一些不同的尝试。第四季。但这一次，我们做了一些不同的尝试。
So, in Gone South Season 4, we'll be bringing you new stories every week, with no end in sight. I'm Jed Lapinski. Welcome back to Gone South, an Odyssey Original Podcast. Listen and follow now on the free Odyssey app, or wherever you get your podcasts, for new episodes every week. We are back. This episode starts over in accounting.
所以，在《深入南方》第四季中，我们将每周为您带来全新的故事，永无止境。我是杰德·拉平斯基。欢迎回到奥德赛原创播客《深入南方》。现在就在免费的奥德赛应用程序上，或在你获取播客的任何地方收听并关注，每周都有新剧集。我们回来了。这一集从会计部开始。
Oscar is holding Philip. Philip's being a little fussy and Dwight comes over and offers to hold him. And immediately Philip stops crying. I want you guys to know this really happened. If you notice, there's no cutaways because when Rain held the baby, the baby actually stopped crying instantly. It was really amazing.
奥斯卡抱着菲利普。菲利普有点闹腾，德怀特走过来主动提出抱抱他。菲利普立刻就不哭了。我想让你们知道这真的发生了。如果你注意到的话，没有任何镜头切换，因为当雷恩抱起那个婴儿时，婴儿真的瞬间停止了哭泣。这真的很神奇。
And if you watch Oscar's reaction, it's really earnest. He's like, wow, I'm impressed. Rain is the baby whisperer. Well, this was a callback to the viewing party episode in season seven when Dwight is the only oneer. Well, this was a callback to the viewing party episode in season seven when Dwight is the only one who can calm Cece. That was like a plot point of that episode. But when we got on set, we found that it was also true that Rain Wilson could calm babies.
如果你观察奥斯卡的反应，那真的很真诚。他就像是，哇，我印象深刻。雷恩是婴儿耳语者。好吧，这是对第七季中观看派对那一集的呼应，当时德怀特是唯一一个。好吧，这是对第七季观看派对那一集的呼应，当时德怀特是唯一一个能让西西平静下来的人。那是那一集的一个剧情点。但当我们到了片场时，我们发现雷恩·威尔逊确实能安抚婴儿，这也是真的。
Yes, it's just so wild. I mean, he is a tall person. I think maybe they feel safe in his arms. He's kind of like a big person to I think maybe they feel safe in his arms. He's kind of like a big person to wrap arms around you. I don't know. He's the baby whisperer. Well now Dwight is going to take Philip into his office. He's actually on a mission to find out now if maybe Philip is really his son. So they're going to play a game called Shroot or Consequences. How great were our toddler actors, Vince and Evan?
是的，太疯狂了。我的意思是，他个子很高。我想也许他们在他的怀里感到安全。他就像是一个大个子，我想也许他们在他的怀里感到安全。他就像是一个大个子，张开双臂环抱你。我不知道。他是婴儿耳语者。现在德怀特要把菲利普带进他的办公室。他实际上带着一个任务，要弄清楚菲利普现在是不是真的是他的儿子。所以他们要玩一个名为“舒鲁特或后果”的游戏。我们的幼儿演员文斯和埃文表现得有多棒？
I know. So cute. So, so good. Well, you know, in this scene, Dwight is trying to get Philip to choose between a dirty old beat or a check for a million dollars. And I don't know who appeared in this scene if it was Vince or Evan, but he was only supposed to point to the beat. But he said, beat.
我知道。太可爱了。太棒了。好吧，你知道，在这个场景中，德怀特试图让菲利普在一根脏兮兮的旧甜菜和一张一百万美元的支票之间做出选择。我不知道出现在这个场景里的是文斯还是埃文，但他本来只应该指着甜菜。但他却说，甜菜。
Oh, it's so cute. And Dave said he was so excited. I bet. But just everything, he put his little hand in his jean pocket. It was so, gosh, it was so cute. So you know, lady, I was a producer on this season.
哦，太可爱了。戴夫说他当时兴奋极了。我敢打赌。但最绝的是，他把小手插进了牛仔裤口袋里。太，天哪，太可爱了。所以你知道吗，女士，我是这一季的制片人。
And one of the things that's really cool about that is that I have a lot of digital clutter. And so I'm gonna get out a little producer digital clutter for you. Yay. So I'm not very good at saving personal emails, but when I've produced things, I keep very detailed folders for my producing work.
其中一件很酷的事情是，我有很多数字杂物。所以我要为你翻出一点制片人的数字杂物。耶。所以我不擅长保存个人电子邮件，但当我制作节目时，我会为我的制片工作保留非常详细的文件夹。
So I went into my folder and I found a document titled, Shrooty Things Baby Philip Can Do. Okay. So sometimes the writers would do a breakout room. Yeah. Where they would just pick a few writers to go into a room and sit there and pitch ideas on a very specific thing. So here are some of the things that were pitched that did not make it.
所以我进入我的文件夹，找到了一份文档，标题是《婴儿菲利普可以做的舒鲁特式事情》。好的。有时编剧们会开一个头脑风暴会议。是的。他们会挑选几位编剧进到一个房间里坐下来，就某个非常具体的事情提出创意。所以以下是一些被提出但最终没有被采用的想法。
The baby crushes an empty soda can in his hands. Philip eats dirt from Dwight's potted plant. Angela says he has never eaten dirt before. Dwight realizes the dirt in the plant is from shrewt farms. This one I really liked. The baby keeps walking into the manager's office. People joke that he really wants to be manager. That's cute. And Dwight notices. This one also made me chuckle. Pam's mom brings her baby Philip into the office
婴儿在手中捏碎一个空苏打罐。菲利普吃德怀特盆栽植物里的泥土。安吉拉说他以前从未吃过泥土。德怀特意识到植物里的泥土来自舒鲁特农场。我真的很喜欢这个：婴儿一直走进经理办公室。人们开玩笑说他真的很想当经理。真可爱。德怀特注意到了。这个也让我咯咯笑了。帕姆的妈妈把她的婴儿菲利普带到了办公室
and Jim's Philip pranks Dwight's Philip. And finally, Dwight has a spare mustard colored shirt hanging on the back of his office door. Philip pulls it down and covers himself with it like a blanket. That's cute too. I know, but this was like a three page document of all the different things that baby Philip might do to reveal that he's actually Dwight's son. Our writers were the best. The best.
然后吉姆的菲利普恶作剧了德怀特的菲利普。最后，德怀特办公室门后挂着一件备用的芥末黄色衬衫。菲利普把它拽下来，像毯子一样盖在自己身上。这也挺可爱的。我知道，但这是一份三页的文档，记录了婴儿菲利普可能会做的所有不同事情，以此来暴露他其实是德怀特的儿子。我们的编剧是最好的。最好的。
That's what they would also do with talking heads. Yes. And that's how we would get candy bags. Our next scene takes us to the break room. I absolutely love this Darryl runner in this episode where everyone wants to spend time with him. They're really bummed he did the Irish exit. And Aaron says, okay, listen, for the the next 12 hours we each get 90 minute segments with
这也是他们在面对镜头独白（Talking Heads）时会做的事情。是的。这就是我们如何获得糖果袋的方法。下一个场景把我们带到了茶水间。我非常喜欢这一集里达里尔的这条支线，每个人都想跟他共度时光。他们对他悄悄溜走感到非常沮丧。亚伦说，好吧，听着，在接下来的 12 小时里，我们每个人都有 90 分钟的时段来和
Darryl. And Darryl's like whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a minute, okay? Maybe I made the mistake of sneaking out of here, that's on me, but I'm not gonna spend the rest of the day here doing stuff with you guys because you're feeling sentimental. And they're instantly like, no you have to! So Dar Darrell said, fine, pick one thing, one thing, and I'm gonna do it with all of y'all. We don't know what that thing's gonna be, but they've gotta go figure it out. Well, now we're gonna check in on Andy Bernard.
达里尔相处。达里尔说：等等，等等，等等，等一下，好吗？也许我悄悄溜走是我的不对，那是我的问题，但我不会把今天剩下的时间留在这里跟你们一起瞎胡闹，就因为你们现在多愁善感。他们立刻说：不，你必须这样！所以达里尔说：好吧，挑一件事，就一件事，我跟你们所有人一起做。我们不知道那会是什么事，但他们得去想办法。好吧，现在我们要去看看安迪·伯纳德。
The last time we saw him, he was frustrated because he felt like there were certain contestants who had feel good stories and they were getting more attention than the other people in the line. Yeah, so Andy was going to make sure he had a feel-good moment. He's going to rejoin the line dressed as an older man.
我们上次见到他时，他很沮丧，因为他觉得某些参赛选手有感人的故事，而他们比排队的其他人在得到了更多的关注。是的，所以安迪要确保自己也有一个感人的时刻。他要重新排队，打扮成一个老人的样子。
He has put on age makeup. But Casey Dean just recognizes him immediately. And Andy's like, no, no, no, I'm an old man. She's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, I get it. Yeah, and she's like, you are shorter than before. And he's like, yeah, I took my lifts out because this character is my real height, unlike Andy Bernard.
他化了老年妆。但凯西·迪恩一眼就认出了他。安迪说：不，不，不，我是个老人。她说：行啦，行啦，行啦，我懂。是的，她说：你比以前矮了。他说：对，我把内增高鞋垫拿出来了，因为这个角色才是我的真实身高，不像安迪·伯纳德。
Lady, this sent me on a Google search. I became really curious about lifts in your shoes and how those work. Well, there's a lot in Hollywood. Well, that's why I got curious about it because I've heard that. I've heard that the male stars wear the lifts in their shoes.
女士，这让我开启了一场谷歌搜索。我对鞋里的内增高鞋垫以及它们是如何运作的产生了强烈的好奇。好吧，好莱坞有很多这种东西。嗯，这就是为什么我对它感到好奇，因为我听说过。我听说过男明星会在鞋里穿内增高鞋垫。
If they're a little shorter. Yeah, but I'm like, how does it work? Well, I guess that you can wear a regular shoe and it's just like how you imagine. There's like just a little wedge that you can wear a regular shoe and it's just like how you imagine. There's like just a little wedge that you put inside the sole and then it bumps you up a little bit. Also, you might see some of your shorter male actors
如果他们个子稍微矮一点的话。是的，但我在想，这是怎么运作的？好吧，我想你可以穿一双普通的鞋，这就像你想象的那样。里面有一个小楔形垫，你可以穿一双普通的鞋，这就像你想象的那样。鞋底里面塞一个小楔形垫，然后就能把你的身高稍微垫高一点。另外，你可能会看到一些个子较矮的男演员
in a lot of cowboy boots. Oh. Cause they have a little bit of a heel. That's a natural lift, right? Like just the shoe gives you a lift. Right. Well, I guess one of the problems with putting lifts in your shoes is that if you go more than,
穿着许多牛仔靴。哦。因为它们有一个小小的鞋跟。那是自然的增高，对吧？就像鞋子本身就能给你增高一样。没错。好吧，我猜在鞋里放内增高鞋垫的一个问题是，如果你超过了
I mean, a half inch, then your heel pops out the back of your shoe. So you can actually end up walking out of your shoes. So they invented something called elevator shoes that look like a regular shoe, but they're more like a woman's wedge, like a wedge heel. Oh, I'm sorry. Are you talking about a sneaker
我是说半英寸，然后你的脚后跟就会从鞋子后面滑出来。所以你实际上最后可能会把鞋子“走掉”。因此他们发明了一种叫做“内增高鞋”的东西，它看起来像一双普通的鞋，但更像是女式楔形鞋，就像楔跟鞋一样。哦，对不起。你说的是运动鞋
that might have a little heel built in? No, no. Not what I'm wearing? Not what I'm wearing, no. That is not an elevator shoe because I can see that it has an exaggerated heel. Oh, it's sneaky. Yes, the elevator shoe.
里面可能内置了一个小鞋跟？不，不。不是我穿的那种？不是我穿的那种，不是。那不是内增高鞋，因为我能看出它有夸张的鞋跟。哦，它很隐蔽。是的，内增高鞋。
I watched a whole YouTube video on it by this guy who was reviewing the best elevator shoes. He was riveting. And yeah, it looks like a beautiful, I think it's even an Italian-made leather businessman shoe. But on the inside, I don't know, it's like the way they designed it. It just looks like businessman shoe. But on the inside, I don't know. It's like the way they designed it. It just looks like a shoe.
我看了关于它的一整段 YouTube 视频，是一个评测最佳内增高鞋的家伙做的。他讲得引人入胜。是的，它看起来像一双漂亮的、我想甚至是由意大利制造的皮革商务鞋。但在内部，我不知道，它的设计方式。它看起来就像商务鞋。但在内部，我不知道。它的设计方式。它看起来就像一双普通的鞋。
But it makes you like two inches taller. That's a lot. It is. I would be like 5'3". I don't know. Maybe you need an elevator shoe. I have questions. What's it like to walk in them?
但它能让你高两英寸左右。那挺多的。确实。我差不多会变成 5 英尺 3 英寸。我不知道。也许你需要一双内增高鞋。我有一些问题。穿着它们走路是什么感觉？
Can you turn your ankle easily? No, it's easy to walk. According to the video, they're really comfortable and easy to walk in and actually better than putting a lift in your shoe because this forms around your foot. The lift, this guy was saying, is actually kind of dangerous because you can walk out of your shoe, you can twist your ankle, you're not actually getting good arch support. So gentlemen out there, if you're looking for a lift, I guess the elevator shoe is what you should look into.
你能轻易扭到脚踝吗？不，走路很轻松。根据视频的说法，它们真的很舒适，走起路来很轻松，实际上比在鞋里塞内增高鞋垫更好，因为这些鞋垫是按你的脚型定制的。这个视频里的人说，鞋垫实际上有点危险，因为你可能会把鞋子走脱，你可能会扭伤脚踝，你实际上并没有得到良好的足弓支撑。所以各位男士，如果你在寻找增高方式，我想内增高鞋就是你应该考虑的东西。
Is your way to go. Mm-hmm. Now the lift, obviously, you can put in and out of different pairs of shoes, which I guess gives you variety, but I don't know. Well Andy Bernard probably would love an elevator shoe. I think he would, but not for this character, not for old man. No, not for old man. Old man is shorter. Well, you know, Andy dressing up as an old man isn't going to help him because someone that
是你的不二之选。嗯哼。现在，鞋垫显然可以放进不同的鞋子里拿进拿出，我想这能给你带来多样性，但我不知道。好吧，安迪·伯纳德可能会喜欢内增高鞋。我想他会喜欢的，但不是为了这个角色，不是为了演老人。对，不是为了演老人。老人个子更矮。好吧，你知道，安迪打扮成老人也没用，因为某个
works for the show comes out and says, you know what, we're done taking auditions. They need everyone in the line to go home. And Andy is furious. He's like, no. And he runs past the security guard into the building. Casey's going to help him out. She's like, no, and he runs past the security guard into the building. Casey's gonna help him out. She's gonna form a distraction. She jumps on the security guys back. And I love her last moment where she's like,
为节目工作的人走出来说，你知道吗，我们不接受试镜了。他们需要队伍里的每个人都回家。安迪勃然大怒。他说：不。然后他冲过保安冲进大楼。凯西要帮他一把。她说：不。然后他冲过保安冲进大楼。凯西要帮他一把。她要制造一个干扰。她跳到了保安的背上。我喜欢她最后的时刻，当时她说：
you won't be seeing the last of Casey Dean. We love Casey Dean, but Andy makes it inside. He does. The audition moderator who gave the bad news is Ryan Bailey. He's been on Chicago Med Arrested Development and How I Met Your Mother. And you know, last week, we had these great audio clips
你们不会是最后一次见到凯西·迪恩的。我们爱凯西·迪恩，但安迪成功进去了。他确实进去了。带来坏消息的试镜主持人是瑞安·贝利。他曾出演过《芝加哥急救》、《发展受阻》和《老爸老妈浪漫史》。而且你知道，上周我们有这些精彩的音频剪辑
from Jessica St. Clair, who played Casey Dean. And she told us an amazing story about this scene right here. You have to hear it. Something that was funny and weird was that I was, I believe, like four months pregnant, but I hadn't told anybody. And so I did share it with the makeup artist because I was like, sorry, my face is so puffy and I look a little bit like the Hulk. But, you know, I'm pregnant. I haven't told anybody yet. And so she's like, okay, okay. And there is a scene where I have to jump on the back of a security guard who's trying to like drag me off the set. And I really wanted
来自杰西卡·圣克莱尔，她饰演凯西·迪恩。她给我们讲了一个关于这一幕的惊人故事。你必须听听。有趣又怪异的一件事是，我当时，我想大概怀孕四个月了，但我没有告诉任何人。所以我有跟化妆师分享这件事，因为我说，抱歉，我的脸好肿，我看起来有点像绿巨人。但是，你知道，我怀孕了。我还没告诉任何人呢。所以她就说，好吧，好吧。有一个场景是我必须跳到一个保安的背上，保安正试图把我从片场拉走。我真的很想
to impress, you know, the director and, you know, and all this one of my favorite shows. And so I really went crazy and I like launched myself onto this gigantic gentleman like a like a cat, like a rabbit cat. And after the second take, the director ran out and he said, um, I don't want to step into your personal space, but the makeup artist has let me know you're pregnant. You might not want to throw yourself onto that man. So so violently and and so I did spend a couple of takes going god I hope I didn't um I don't hope I didn't knock
给导演留下深刻印象，你知道的，还有这是我最喜欢的节目之一。所以我真的疯狂了，我像一只猫一样，像一只发狂的猫，把自己扑向了这个巨大的绅士。拍完第二个镜头后，导演跑出来说，“嗯，我不想介入你的个人空间，但化妆师告诉我你怀孕了。你可能不想把自己那么暴力地扔到那个男人身上。”所以，所以我在好几个镜头里都在想：“天哪，希望我没有，嗯，希望我没有把那个孩子从肚子里撞出来，那可就太遗憾了。也许为了这个节目这也算值了吧。”
that baby out of me that'd be a real shame maybe it would have been worth it for the show. Oh Jessica she is so funny to me. I know I think she's one of those people that can just read the phone book and I'd be laughing. I know. Is that still an expression? People don't even say it anymore. Because we don't really get phone books anymore. Okay, insert read boring item and I'd still be laughing.
哦，杰西卡，她对我来说太搞笑了。我知道，我觉得她是那种哪怕读电话簿都能把我逗笑的人。我知道。那还是个表达方式吗？人们现在甚至都不说了。因为我们现在真的不怎么拿电话簿了。好吧，插入“阅读无聊的东西但我还是会笑”。
Well, she also sent us in an audio clip just about her general takeaway from getting to do the show and I want you to hear that too. So I was so excited to be with Ed in a scene. Anytime I get to be with someone from the UCB, it's very easy. It's like super easy lifting because you kind of know each other's rhythms and if somebody improvises, you're ready to improvise back with them. I can't remember if there were too many things that were actually improvised. They were short little scenes, but I'm sure there were little bits and bobs back and forth.
好吧，她还给我们发来了一段音频剪辑，谈到她对参演这部剧的总体感受，我也想让你听听。所以我能和埃德同场飙戏感到非常兴奋。任何时候只要能和 UCB（根基喜剧剧团）的人合作，都非常轻松。这就像是轻而易举的事，因为你们多少了解彼此的节奏，如果有人即兴发挥，你随时准备好接住他们的即兴表演。我不记得是否有太多真正即兴发挥的东西。它们都是简短的小场景，但我确信有一些来来回回的小插曲。
One of the things I love about Ed is he's not only wildly funny, but he's quite charming. So I didn't have to act too hard, you know? He's a real gentleman and a scholar. So it was really fun to get to have like a little romantic moment with Ed. And I remember being very panicked that I had to sing. I do that strange like but like I'm not a singer. I mean I'm pretty sure I was kicked out of my college acapella group, the Miscords, because instead of singing the harmony like I was supposed to, I would just sing the melody. And they finally, they were like,
我喜欢埃德的一点是，他不仅极度搞笑，而且相当有魅力。所以我不需要太费力去演，你知道吗？他是个真正的绅士和学者。所以和埃德有一点点浪漫的时刻真的很有趣。我记得我很恐慌，因为我不得不唱歌。我做出那种奇怪的动作，但我不是歌手。我的意思是，我很确定我被大学的无伴奏合唱团“Miscords”开除了，因为我没有像规定那样唱和声，而是只唱主旋律。他们最后说：
we're not hearing any alto. I'm like, and you never will bitches, cause I don't know how to do that. So I remember being a little nervous about singing. I just had to sort of go for it and hope that it wasn't too offensive to anybody's ears. She's so funny. Everything about that clip is so funny to me.
我们听不到任何女低音。我说：你们永远也听不到了，碧池们，因为我根本不会那样做。所以我记得对唱歌有点紧张。我只能硬着头皮上，希望这不会对任何人的耳朵造成太大冒犯。她太搞笑了。那个剪辑里的每件事对我都太搞笑了。
If you guys wanna hear more from Jessica, you have to listen to her podcast, The Deep Dive that she does with June Diane Raphael, or download her audio book, The Art of Small Talk that she did with Casey Wilson, because it's more of that. So funny. Well, now Dwight is gonna return Philip to Angela. Oscar's gonna ask Dwight if he got Philip to eat.
如果你们想听杰西卡更多内容，你们必须去听她的播客《The Deep Dive》，那是她和朱恩·黛安·拉斐尔一起做的，或者下载她和凯西·威尔逊合作的有声书《The Art of Small Talk》，因为里面全都是这种内容。太搞笑了。好吧，现在德怀特要把菲利普还给安吉拉。奥斯卡要问德怀特有没有让菲利普吃东西。
He said he won't take the bottle. And Dwight says it's because he's of superior intelligence. He knows when he's being tricked out of a real breast. And that's when Kevin says, oh yeah, he's not that smart. He doesn't know where I hid his toy duck. Yeah, Kevin. I know. He's still jealous. Now we're going to go to Jim's desk. There is the biggest envelope ever. This is a bullsh** card for me. I was going to play a bullsh** card. Really?
他说他不肯用奶瓶。德怀特说这是因为他智商超群。他知道什么时候自己被骗得吃不到真奶了。就在那时凯文说：哦，对了，他没那么聪明。他都不知道我把他的玩具鸭子藏哪儿去了。没错，凯文。我知道。他还是那么嫉妒。现在我们要去吉姆的桌子旁。那里有一个史上最大的信封。这是一张“胡说八道”牌，是给我的。我正要打出一张“胡说八道”牌。真的吗？
Yes. I was going to finally play a bullsh** card here. You know, last week we talked about how Jim seemed to, on the fly, get an idea that he needed something from the documentary crew, and they immediately agree to whatever favor he needs. Now I'm like, how many hours have passed and they have somehow assembled this disc for him? Nine years of footage. Nine years of footage.
是的。我打算在这里终于打出一张“胡说八道”牌。你知道，上周我们谈到吉姆似乎临时起意，觉得自己需要纪录片摄制组提供点什么，而他们立刻就答应了他需要的任何帮忙。现在我在想，到底过去了几个小时，他们怎么就为他剪辑好这张光盘了？九年的素材。九年的素材。
They edited together so quickly. Well, my bullsh** card wasn't so much about that. It was more, I titled it Big Envelope Cringe. Why? Why is your bullsh** card about the size of the envelope? Because it's like laughable to me. It is a giant gray envelope and then written in huge letters. It says Jim Sharpie. It's like, Cameron, did you catch the envelope? Okay, let's make it bigger. It's like almost the size of like an iPad. Okay, the size of the envelope did not bother me in any way.
他们剪辑得太快了。好吧，我的“胡说八道”牌倒不是针对这个。更多的是，我给它起名为“大信封尴尬”。为什么？为什么你的“胡说八道”牌是关于信封的大小的？因为这对我来说简直荒谬。这是一个巨大的灰色信封，上面用超大字写着。上面写着“Jim Sharpie”。就像是，卡梅伦，你注意到那个信封了吗？好吧，把它做大点。它几乎有 iPad 那么大。好吧，信封的大小对我来说没有任何困扰。
So it felt appropriate for a disc. So we're playing two bulls**t cards. I guess so. I mean, I just want to know how they got through all of this footage so quickly. I mean, impressive. Very impressive. Well, big envelope or not, Jim is very happy to have it.
所以感觉对一张光盘来说挺合适的。所以我们打出了两张“胡说八道”牌。我想是的。我是说，我只是想知道他们是怎么以这么快的速度看完所有这些素材的。我是说，令人印象深刻。非常印象深刻。好吧，不管信封大不大，吉姆很高兴能拥有它。
We're going to go back to the auditions. The last person is on stage. It's a young woman. Yes, she's very talented. She's singing Beautiful by Christina Aguilera. And it's going very well for her. So this gal who's singing, her name is Rachel Crowe. And she was a
我们要回到试镜现场。最后一个人上台了。是一个年轻女性。是的，她非常有才华。她正在唱克里斯蒂娜·阿奎莱拉的《Beautiful》。她的表现非常顺利。所以这个唱歌的姑娘，她名叫雷切尔·克罗。她曾是
contestant on the first season of The X Factor when she was 13 years old. I have an audio clip. But I gotta say it's true. My morals got me on my knees. I'm begging, please stop playing games. I mean, that's amazing. She brought down the house. She went all the way to the quarterfinal round. And after that, she went on to star in the TV series Schooled.
《X音素》第一季的参赛选手，当时她只有 13 岁。我有一段音频剪辑。但我得说这是真的。我的道德让我双膝跪地。我恳求着，求求你们别玩游戏了。我的意思是，这太棒了。她燃爆了全场。她一路杀入了四分之一决赛。在那之后，她继续主演了电视剧《校园模范生》。
She did our show. She's done a fair amount of work in animation. In fact, she's the voice of Tip in the Netflix show, Home Adventures with Tip and O. She's phenomenal. What a voice. I know. Well, I was gonna point out one other person in the scene
她出演了我们的节目。她做了相当多的动画配音工作。事实上，她是 Netflix 剧集《家园：蒂普与奥的奇妙冒险》中蒂普的配音。她太惊艳了。好一副嗓子。我知道。好吧，我要指出场景中的另一个人
and that is Clay Aiken. I was really rooting for him in American Idol. I will never forget his performance of Bridge Over Troubled Waters. Oh, right. So good. Yeah. And I brought a clip of that. I'm loving today. I will ease your mind Like a bridge over troubled water
那就是克莱·艾肯。我当时在《美国偶像》里真的很支持他。我永远不会忘记他演唱的《Bridge Over Troubled Water》（恶水上的大桥）。哦，对的。太棒了。是的。我带来了那段剪辑。我爱死今天了。我会让你安心 就像恶水上的大桥
I will ease your mind Your mind Ooh, that still packs a punch. I mean, I get chills. It's so beautiful. Wow. Wow. Well, let's see. I've got a little location breakdown for you. We shot this on location. All of us had the day off. It was two days off. Ed filmed these scenes. They were in Burbank, and we did not get to meet any of these folks on the day. No, we didn't. I know. Well, Andy is going to try to sing for them, and it does not go well at all. Yes, he enters as the old man,
我会抚平你的心 你的心 噢，那依然很有冲击力。我的意思是，我起鸡皮疙瘩了。太美了。哇。哇。好吧，让我想想。我给你们准备了一点外景剖析。我们在实景地拍摄了这一段。我们所有人都放假了。放了两天假。埃德拍摄了这些场景。它们在伯班克，我们那天没有见到任何这些演员。不，我们没有。我知道。好吧，安迪要尝试为他们唱歌，结果一点也不顺利。是的，他以老人的身份出场，
but it's very clear he's not really an old man. Aaron Rogers calls him out, but he's going to go ahead and start singing. He's going to sing You're Never Fully Dressed Without a Smile. And you know what? They aren't feeling it. They're not feeling it. So he quickly switches gears and he starts singing the Cornell fight song. Yep. I was curious if that is the actual Cornell fight song. I assume it was. And I found a compilation of Cornell acapella groups singing it. Well, okay. Oh, that's precious. How perfect is it though that they're acapella groups?
但很明显他并不是真正的老人。亚伦·罗杰斯指出了这一点，但他还是要开始唱歌。他要唱《You're Never Fully Dressed Without a Smile》（没有微笑，你便不算盛装出席）。你知道吗？他们并不感冒。他们不买账。所以他迅速转换策略，开始唱康奈尔大学的校歌。是的。我很好奇这真的是康奈尔大学的校歌吗？我猜是的。我找到了康奈尔大学无伴奏合唱团演唱它的合集。好吧，好的。哦，太珍贵了。不过，他们都是无伴奏合唱团，这有多完美啊？
Andy would be so proud, but the judges are not impressed. They're not. And then Andy has a full meltdown. Yeah, I can see them all trying not to laugh. All of the judges are trying not to laugh. Yes, I asked Sonti Gold about this. Here's what she had to say. I think for me, probably the funniest part
安迪会为此感到非常骄傲，但评委们并不买账。他们不买账。然后安迪彻底崩溃了。是的，我能看到他们都在极力忍住不笑。所有的评委都在极力忍住不笑。是的，我问过桑蒂·戈德关于这部分的事。她是这么说的。我想对我来说，可能最搞笑的部分
and the hardest part to hold it together was when I said to him that he couldn't just sit there and cry and he's like, I can't so just sit here and cry. And he's like really like yells it just now watching it. I watched it and like I forgot the whole thing. And it's so funny. I mean, he did it differently every time. So every time was like new opportunities to crack up laughing.
也是最难憋住不笑的部分，就是当我对他说了他不能就坐在那儿哭，然后他说：我不能，所以只能坐这儿哭。然后他真的很像那样大喊，就刚刚看的时候。我看了，然后就像是把整件事都忘了。太搞笑了我。我的意思是，他每次演都不一样。所以每一次都像是获得爆笑的新机会。
So but I think that's part of the fun of it to have to hold it together is also the fun of it and and to come up with like other things to do besides laugh. But I really enjoyed it. I mean, it was kind of like everything that I thought that I wanted it to be. It was. And I remember talking to my friend who was like my main friend that we love the office together. And I told him that I was on the office and he believed me and he's like, you kidding me? You know, because it was like a dream for that to be the first thing to do. And also because it's so many years later now and a lot of people had no idea that I was ever even on there and you know, The Office has had such a continually growing fan base, it seems like it had
所以，但我认为这也是其中的乐趣所在，要憋住不笑也是乐趣的一部分，并且想出除了笑之外的其他事情可做。但我真的很享受。我的意思是，这有点像我想象中它应该成为的样子。确实是。我记得我和我的朋友交谈过，他是我最好的朋友，我们一起热爱《办公室》。我告诉他我参演了《办公室》，他相信了，他说：你在开玩笑吧？你知道，因为能把这作为第一件要做的事就像是一个梦想。而且也是因为现在已经过去很多年了，很多人甚至不知道我曾经参演过，你知道，《办公室》的粉丝基础似乎一直在持续增长，它看起来
a whole new life all over again, which is great, it's like a legacy. And so people have discovered me on the end, on the end episodes and been like, oh my God, are you in the office? It's really funny, because it's so unexpected and it's such a nice surprise. So it just keeps, it keeps surprising people all these years later.
焕发了全新的人气，这太棒了，就像是一种传承。所以人们在结尾几集里发现了我的身影，然后说：哦天哪，你在《办公室》里吗？这真的很好笑，因为这太出乎意料了，而且是一个如此美好的惊喜。所以这么多年过去了，它依然在给人们带来惊喜。
So Angela, since I knew that this was Santi's first on-camera acting job, I just kind of asked her in general, like, how was that, like, coming onto the set? And she told a story that I think you'll enjoy. Here it is. Yeah, so the day of, I remember coming there, they told us to wear our own clothes
所以安吉拉，既然我知道这是桑蒂的第一个镜头前表演工作，我就大致问了她，来到片场感觉怎么样？她讲了一个我觉得你会喜欢的故事。就是这样。是的，所以那天，我记得来到那里，他们告诉我们穿我们自己的衣服
because we were supposed to be playing ourselves. So that part was simple. We just got, you know, just got out of hair and makeup and then went in, and it was just me, Clay Aiken, and Aaron Rodgers. And I knew who Clay Aiken was, but I did not know who Aaron Rodgers was. And I don't know anything about football. So I asked him, I said, oh, what do you do? And he's like, oh, I'm a football player. I said, what team do you play for? And he said, I believe he said the Green Bay Packers, if that's a team. I'm so bad, I still don't know
因为我们应该扮演我们自己。所以那部分很简单。我们只是，你知道，刚做完发型和化妆，然后就进去了，当时只有我、克莱·艾肯和亚伦·罗杰斯。我认识克莱·艾肯，但我不知道亚伦·罗杰斯是谁。我对橄榄球一无所知。所以我问他，我说，哦，你是做什么的？他说，哦，我是一名橄榄球运动员。我说，你效力于哪个队？他说，我想他说的是绿湾包装工队，如果这是一个队的话。我太糟糕了，我还是不知道
about football. And then I asked him, what city was that? And he told me, and for some reason I thought he was joking. And I was like, no, for real, what city is it? And he was like, no, that really is it. So it was kind of a funny intro. We ended up getting along really well and having a lot of fun throughout the day. But yeah, it was, I mean, I remember that they were changing the lines a lot, which made me feel a little bit anxious because I'm not used to that and obviously didn't have any experience with that, with, I mean, with any of it at all. It was also new, but like the improvisational aspect was so actually fun to be in and watch
关于橄榄球的事。然后我问他，那是哪个城市？他告诉我了，出于某种原因我以为他在开玩笑。我说：不，说真的，到底是哪个城市？他说：不，那真的就是。所以这是一个有点搞笑的开场。我们最后相处得非常融洽，一整天都玩得很开心。但确实，我的意思是，我记得他们经常改台词，这让我觉得有点焦虑，因为我不习惯那样，而且显然对此没有任何经验，我是说，对这一切完全没有经验。一切都是崭新的，但即兴发挥的方面实际上非常有趣，能身处其中并看着
Ed Helms just master. He was so funny. And yeah, it was hard not to laugh, but at the same time, it was fun to just be in it with him and just get to experience it and not fall apart. But we did it obviously several times and every time he did it different and every time it was like hilarious. And so I always, I don't know, I always just really have a fun time watching people who master their crafts and just being able
埃德·海尔姆斯展现大师级演技。他太搞笑了。是的，要忍住不笑很难，但与此同时，能和他一起沉浸其中，去体验它而不笑场，这很有趣。但我们显然拍了好几次，每次他演都不一样，每次都爆笑如雷。所以我总是，我不知道，我总是非常享受观看那些精通自己手艺的人，并且能够
to just be a witness of it. So I remember the experience being more like me getting to watch him. I'm really, really enjoying that and just being part of it at all, you know. really enjoying that and just being part of it at all, you know. Lady, I just love this runner of people asking Aaron Rogers, what is it that you do? Oh, football. That's so neat.
成为这一切的见证者。所以我记得这段经历更像是看着他表演。我真的，真的很享受这一点，能成为其中的一部分，你知道的。真的非常享受，并且能成为其中的一部分，你知道的。女士，我太喜欢这种人们问亚伦·罗杰斯“你是做什么的？”的支线了。哦，橄榄球。太酷了。
Like, I don't know why it's just very funny to me. Well, in my experience, he was really kind in the moment. Well, Dave Rogers said all three of these guys were so great to work with. He remembered that Clay Aiken was really funny and had a great sense of humor, and he said he was really great at doing improv. Dave said that Aaron Rogers was really down-to-earth, super friendly. He came in really prepared. He knew all his lines and gave great reactions. He really came off very relaxed and natural. And he said that our editor, Claire Scanlon, was a huge fan of Sante Gold and was so bummed she couldn't be there. So Dave asked if
就像，我不知道为什么这对我来说非常搞笑。好吧，以我的经验来看，他当时真的很友善。好吧，戴夫·罗杰斯说这三个人合作起来都非常棒。他记得克莱·艾肯非常搞笑，幽默感极佳，他说他在即兴表演方面真的很棒。戴夫说亚伦·罗杰斯真的很脚踏实地，超级友善。他来的时候准备得非常充分。他知道所有的台词，反应也非常棒。他给人的感觉真的很放松、很自然。他说我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦是桑蒂·戈德的超级粉丝，对没能到现场感到非常沮丧。所以戴夫问
Sante would mind writing her a note and autographing it and giving it to Claire and Claire was over the moon. That is so sweet of Dave and so thoughtful. I know. But also so nice of Santi Gold to be like, sure, no problem. I know. Well, I want to give a big thank you to Santi for sending in all those audio clips. You know, she has a podcast as well, Ange.
桑蒂介不介意给她写张便条并签个名，送给克莱尔，克莱尔当时简直高兴坏了。戴夫太贴心、太周到了。我知道。但桑蒂·戈德说“当然，没问题”也超级nice。我知道。好吧，我要对桑蒂寄来所有这些音频剪辑表示巨大的感谢。你知道，她也有一个播客，安吉。
It's called Noble Champions. And here's how it is described. Noble Champions is a modern day salon created and hosted by the multi-platform visionary artist, Santi Gold. In each episode, she sits down with some of today's leading artists, authors, activists, and progressive thinkers who stand up, stick up, and speak up for important causes. The first season is out now, and speak up for important causes. The first season is out now and she's going to have new episodes premiering this fall,
它叫《Noble Champions》（高尚的冠军）。它是这样描述的。《高尚的冠军》是一个由多平台远见卓识的艺术家桑蒂·戈德创建并主持的现代沙龙。在每一集中，她都会与当今一些领先的艺术家、作家、活动家和进步思想家坐在一起，他们为重要的事业挺身而出、坚持不懈、大声疾呼。第一季现已上线，并为重要的事业大声疾呼。第一季现已上线，今年秋天她将推出全新剧集，
so check it out. Great. We'll put that in our stories. I would love to give her a shout out as well. I love NPR's Tiny Desk Concert series and Santi Gold's is so great. So if you're a fan of that series and haven't seen hers, it's a great watch and I'll put that in stories as well. Great.
所以去看看吧。太棒了。我们会把它放到快拍里。我也很想向她大声致敬。我喜欢 NPR 的“Tiny Desk Concert”系列，而桑蒂·戈德的那期太棒了。所以如果你是那个系列的粉丝而且还没看过她的那一期，那绝对值得一看，我也会把它放到快拍里。太棒了。
Well, why don't we go to break? Because when we come back, Philip and Kevin are finally gonna make amends. Well, I wanna go to break because Angela, you brought in like two coolers worth of food today and I've been waiting patiently to get to eat it. Will you tell everybody what it is? Yeah, so Josh and I sold a cookbook. I've shared that with you guys.
好吧，我们为什么不去休息一下呢？因为当我们回来时，菲利普和凯文终于要言归于好了。好吧，我想去休息一下，因为安吉拉，你今天带来了相当于两个冰盒那么多的食物，我一直在耐心地等待吃它。你能不能告诉大家那是什么？好吧，所以我和乔许卖了一本食谱。我已经和你们分享过这个了。
Yeah. And this week is the cookbook photography. And what that means is we're making like 11 recipes a day and then professionally food styling and taking the photos. It's turning out so fantastic. But it also means every day Josh is bringing home like 11 recipes. My fridge was so full, so today I said, you guys, I'm bringing in food for everyone. I have lasagna rolls. I have an amazing chicken and rice soup.
是的。这周是食谱摄影周。这意味着我们每天要做大约 11 道菜，然后进行专业的食物造型和拍照。结果太棒了。但这也意味着乔许每天都要带回家大约 11 道菜。我的冰箱太满了，所以我今天说，各位，我为大家带了吃的。我有千层面卷。我有一款超赞的鸡肉米饭汤。
I also have brisket with all the sides. I also have chocolate chip muffins. I have millionaire bars, no-bake chocolate and oatmeal drops, an almond cake. So we're going to have a feast at lunch. You told me about this last night and I've been distracted because I can't wait any longer. The coolers are sitting right next to me. We'll be are back.
我还带了牛胸肉以及所有的配菜。我还有巧克力奇普松饼。我有百万富翁条、免烤巧克力燕麦球和杏仁蛋糕。所以我们午餐要大吃一顿了。你昨晚跟我说过这个，我已经分心了，因为我再也等不及了。冰盒就放在我旁边。我们马上回来。
Our bellies are full. I just ate the most delicious brisket with potatoes and carrots. And then I had a pecan cookie for dessert. Yes, Josh, you fed us all today. Thank you so much. And all of these things that I just ate are going to be in the cookbook, Ange? Yes. I know. This is going to be a good cookbook.
我们的肚子都填饱了。我刚刚吃了最美味的牛胸肉配土豆和胡萝卜。然后我吃了佩坎山核桃饼干作为甜点。是的，乔许，你今天把我们都喂饱了。非常感谢。我刚刚吃的这些东西都会收录在食谱里吗，安吉？是的。我知道。这将是一本好食谱。
It's looking so beautiful, too. I'm really excited about it. Well, we're going to head over to accounting and Oscar and Angela. They need to try to smooth things over with Kevin. So they're going to present him with a gift from Philip. Yes, Philip got Kevin a $25 iTunes gift card. There's only $7 left on it. Yeah. But it's from Philip.
它看起来也太漂亮了。我对此真的很兴奋。好吧，我们要去会计部了，奥斯卡和安吉拉。他们需要设法和凯文修复关系。所以他们要送他一份来自菲利普的礼物。是的，菲利普送给凯文一张 25 美元的 iTunes 礼品卡。里面只剩 7 美元了。是的。但那是菲利普送的。
And Kevin is very moved by this. He has a talking head where he says he and Philip are gonna be best friends. Yeah, he's kind of standoffish at first, but you know, he likes you when he starts buying you things. I mean, this is the advice that they give you if you're going to have a second kid. They say have the baby buy a gift for the first kid. I've never heard them up. Oh, you didn't know that? I didn't. Oh, my gosh. I mean, I remember I was five years old when my little sister Emily was born and she gave me
凯文对此非常感动。他有一个面对镜头的独白，说他和菲利普会成为最好的朋友。是的，他一开始有点冷淡，但你知道，当你开始给他买东西时，他就喜欢你了。我的意思是，如果你打算生第二个孩子，人们就是这么建议你的。他们说让大宝收到二宝买的礼物。我从来没听说过这个。哦，你不知道吗？我不知道。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我记得我五岁时，我的小妹妹艾米丽出生了，她在
in the hospital when I visited her my parents were like, Emily got you this and it was a little dog and I named it Prancy and it was my favorite stuffed animal and I still have it on my shelf in my office today. And I guess when you're that little you you're not like, oh, the baby can't walk or speak, but bought me a gift. Yeah. I mean, I immediately liked her. I was like, this kid is terrific. This kid is really good at giving gifts. Yeah. Well, that says a lot about Kevin, where he's at.
医院里我去看她时，我父母说，艾米丽给你买了这个，那是一只小狗，我给它取名叫普兰西，它是我最喜欢的毛绒玩具，直到今天它还放在我办公室的架子上。我想当你那么小时，你不会觉得，哦，这个婴儿不会走路也不会说话，但她给我买了一份礼物。是的。我的意思是，我立刻就喜欢上她了。我当时想，这小孩太棒了。这小孩真会送礼物。是的，这说明了凯文的现状。
I know, right? He's about a five-year-old. Yeah. Well, the whole group has decided what they want to do with Darryl. They have decided they all want to dance with him. And Darryl says, all right, you're going to need some good speakers. Let's go. I do have a bullsh** card to play here in Darryl's office. What is it?
我知道，对吧？他就像个五岁的小孩。是的。好吧，整个团队已经决定了他们想对达里尔做什么。他们决定都想跟他跳舞。而达里尔说，好吧，你们需要一些好的音响。我们走吧。我在达里尔的办公室里确实有一张胡扯牌可以打。是什么？
Darryl left. He got his things and he left. And he had no plans to come back to his office, right? Sure. Well, guess what was sitting in the corner? What? He got his things and he left. And he had no plans to come back to his office, right? Sure. Well, guess what was sitting in the corner? What? His fakey bass fish thing.
达里尔走了。他拿了东西就走了。他根本没打算回办公室，对吧？当然。好吧，猜猜角落里放着什么？什么？他拿了东西就走了。他根本没打算回办公室，对吧？当然。好吧，猜猜角落里放着什么？什么？他那条假低音鱼摆设。
Oh, that he brought up from the warehouse to this? Yes! He left it behind, along with a box of some other things, but sitting right there is the fakey bass thing. You know what? I'm going to say he did that on purpose. He's not, he's not taking it with him. Maybe he doesn't need that in his snazzy new athlete office.
哦，他从仓库搬到这来的那个？对！他把它落下了，还有一箱其他东西，但那个假鱼摆设就那样放在那。你知道吗？我要说他是故意这样的。他才没有，他没把它带走。也许他在他那个时髦的新运动员办公室里不需要这个。
I guess not. Maybe he's going for a new decor now that he's like a big deal agent guy. So he just left it. He's like, anyone want it? It's here. Yeah, maybe. Dwight has called Angela into his office. He tells her to close the door and have a seat. He believes Philip may be a shrewt. And as such, Philip is entitled to a farm and inheritance and the right kind of upbringing, you know, under rigorous shrewt traditions. He also says that Angela will be compensated with a marriage proposal as well. It's kind of an afterthought to his speech.
我想也是吧。也许他现在成了一个大经纪人大佬，想换个新装修风格。所以他就把它落下了。他就像是，有人想要吗？它就在这。是的，也许吧。德怀特把安吉拉叫进了他的办公室。他让她关上门坐下。他相信菲利普可能是一个施鲁特人。因此，菲利普有权拥有一座农场、遗产以及接受正确的教育，你知道的，要遵循严格的施鲁特传统。他还说安吉拉将获得求婚作为补偿。这听起来有点像他演讲完后的临时起意。
And there was a lot to play in this scene. At first, Dave wanted me to be excited about the idea of Dwight raising Philip. But then when he says, and of course a marriage proposal will be also offered to you, I'm supposed to then turn and be like, no, that's not how I want this. And so once again, Angela says, Philip is not your son, and she leaves. Yeah. Meanwhile, in the break room, Jim has brought Pam in, and there's a laptop sitting on one of the tables and a DVD. And it's clear, you know, he's gonna play this DVD for her,
而且这场戏里有很多可以发挥的地方。起初，戴夫希望我对德怀特抚养菲利普这个想法感到兴奋。但后来当他说，“当然，还会向你求婚”时，我本该转过身去表现得像，不，这不是我想要的。所以安吉拉再次说道，菲利普不是你的儿子，然后她离开了。是的。与此同时，在茶水间里，吉姆把帕姆带了进来，其中一张桌子上放着一台笔记本电脑和一个DVD。很显然，你知道的，他要给她播放这个DVD，
but Dwight interrupts him. He throws the now bean bag at Jim's head and hits him right in the head. Yeah. Serious. Serious. So is Dwight just walking around with bean bags in his pockets?
但德怀特打断了他。他把那个豆袋扔向吉姆的头，正中头部。真的。认真的。所以德怀特是口袋里揣着豆袋到处走的吗？
Yes. Yes. I believe he is. So Dwight says, I'll be right back. And Pam waits for a second. And then she is like, no, I gotta see what this is. I'm gonna put this DVD in the computer. She doesn't wait that long. She doesn't.
是的。是的。我相信他是这样的。所以德怀特说，我马上回来。帕姆等了一会儿。然后她就想，不，我得看看这是什么。我要把这个DVD放进电脑里。她没等那么久。她真的没等。
And now we're gonna cut back and forth between this scene with Jim and Dwight and what Pam is doing in the break room. I loved the scene, how it cut back and forth. I thought it was so beautiful. I loved seeing the footage of early Pam and Jim. It was really emotional to watch. It was emotional to watch as someone who worked
现在我们要在这场吉姆和德怀特的戏与帕姆在茶水间的举动之间来回切换。我很喜欢这场戏，它剪辑来回切换的方式。我觉得它太美妙了。我喜欢看到早期帕姆和吉姆的影像。看这个真的很让人情绪激动。作为这部剧的工作人员
on the show and was in these scenes to see the progression of the characters, but then as a fan and then as someone who's been rewatching them with her best friend, it was very layered emotion for me. Yeah. Well, we got a few fan questions about this montage that Pam is watching. One from Randy C. in Columbia, Maryland, who said, Jenna, when filming the sequence where Pam watches the DVD, was there anything really on the screen or was it put in during post-production?
并且身处这些场景之中，看到角色的成长过程让人情绪激动，但随后作为一个粉丝，然后作为一个和自己最好的朋友一起重温这部剧的人，这对我来说是多层次的情感。是的。好吧，我们收到了一些关于帕姆正在看的这个蒙太奇的粉丝提问。来自马里兰州哥伦比亚市的兰迪·C问：珍娜，在拍摄帕姆看DVD的那段序列时，屏幕上真的有东西，还是后期制作加进去的？
Oh, we also had a fan question from Angela Kay in Los Angeles. What did she say? Jenna, were you actually watching the footage in the video? And may I also add that your performance in the scene is beautiful and made me tear up. I love it. Well, I'll have you both know, Randy and Angela Kay, I was watching it.
哦，我们还收到了洛杉矶安吉拉·K的粉丝提问。她说了什么？珍娜，你当时真的在看视频里的画面吗？我还可以补充说，你在剧中的表演非常优美，让我差点落泪。我太喜欢了。好吧，我要告诉你们俩，兰迪和安吉拉·K，我当时确实在看。
And I was watching it for the first time. Oh wow. When they started rolling. Oh. I knew what was coming. I knew I was gonna see this montage of us as Jim and Pam. But there's no way to prepare yourself for it. There's not.
而且我是第一次看。哦，哇。当它们开始播放的时候。哦。我知道接下来会发生什么。我知道我会看到我们作为吉姆和帕姆的这段蒙太奇。但你根本无法为此做好心理准备。真的没办法。
There were so many wonderful moments. Sarah R from Cleveland, Ohio wanted to know who created the video. It was Claire Scanlon. She collected the images. Dave Rogers gave her a few suggestions. There were a few suggestions in the script. She picked out the song, Open Your Eyes from Snow Patrol.
有太多美好的时刻了。来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰的莎拉·R想知道这个视频是谁制作的。是克莱尔·斯坎伦。她收集了这些图片。戴夫·罗杰斯给了她一些建议。剧本里也有一些建议。她挑选了雪地巡游者乐队的歌曲《Open Your Eyes》。
Dave said that he believes John Krasinski came in and worked on it a little bit with Claire. He knew what was on it, but I did not. But this was the last scene that we shot for this episode. So this was a Friday. It was evening. It was just us on the set. It was very quiet. Really kind of reminded me of when we did Casino Night, when everybody else had gone
戴夫说他相信约翰· Krasinski 进来和克莱尔一起稍微制作了一下。他知道里面有什么，但我不知道。但这 faktisk 是我们为这一集拍摄的最后一个场景。所以这是一个周五。那是傍晚。片场只有我们。非常安静。真的有点让我想起我们拍《赌场之夜》的时候，当时其他人都
home and we had like a smaller group for this really emotional moment between these two characters. Well, I'd also love to give a big shout out to Dave Rogers for how he directed this because I thought it was really beautiful that you watched all of this just heartfelt emotion from Pam. And then Jim is talking to Dwight about Pam at the same time, and Dwight is thinking about Angela. When Jim tells Dwight to forget about fear and doubt and do whatever he can to get the one woman who's going to make everything worth it to just do it. And he says, you love Angela, you probably always have. And Rain is Dwight, his performance is brilliant too. have. And Rain is Dwight. His performance is brilliant too. He's tearing up and he tells Jim he's a good assistant. So there's so much emotion happening in
回家了，我们留了一小群人来拍摄这两个角色之间这个非常感人的时刻。好吧，我也想对戴夫·罗杰斯的导演手法表达大大的感谢，因为我觉得你看着帕姆所有的这些真挚情感真的很美妙。与此同时，吉姆正在和德怀特谈论帕姆，而德怀特正在想着安吉拉。当吉姆告诉德怀特忘掉恐惧和怀疑，尽其所能去追求那个能让一切都变得值得的女人时，就放手去做吧。他说，你爱安吉拉，你可能一直都爱。雷恩饰演的德怀特，他的表演也很精彩。爱。雷恩饰演的德怀特，他的表演也很精彩。他热泪盈眶，告诉吉姆他是个好助手。所以这
these two moments. I thought it was really well done. Well this whole thing ends with Jim walking back into the break room seeing that Pam has watched the video and handing her the original teapot note, the one he took back and put in his pocket all of those years ago. We got a fan question from Lainey B. in Westerville, Ohio, who said, was it always the plan to revisit the teapot card Jim wrote for Pam,
两个时刻包含了太多的情感。我觉得这拍得真的很好。好吧，整个过程以吉姆走回茶水间、看到帕姆看了视频、并把最初那个茶壶便条交还给她而告终，那是他多年前收回并放进口袋的便条。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州韦斯特维尔的莱妮·B的粉丝提问，她问道：重新审视吉姆为帕姆写的茶壶卡片一直是计划好的，
or was it something that the writers remembered and wanted to incorporate into the episode? Lainey, it was not always planned. Like, not from when we did that first Christmas episode, did anybody say, one day we're going to reveal what was on this note. It sort of took on a life of its own. People became so curious what was in the note
还是编剧们记起并想把它融入剧集中的东西？莱妮，这并非从一开始就计划好的。就像，从我们拍摄第一集圣诞节开始，就没人说过，总有一天我们会揭晓这张纸条上写了什么。它某种程度上有了自己的生命。人们变得对纸条里写的内容无比好奇
that Jim didn't give Pam. And I've told this story before, but when we were pitching to Greg about season nine, I said, Greg, we have to read the teapot note. I mean, it's the greatest callback of the whole series. It's brilliant. This is a fantastic idea. Did they lose their minds when you pitched it? Well, I felt like I kind of had to convince them a little bit because... What? Here's the thing.
而吉姆没有交给帕姆。我以前讲过这个故事，但当我们在向格雷格推销第九季时，我说，格雷格，我们必须读一下那个茶壶便条。我的意思是，这是全剧最棒的回应梗。太棒了。这是一个绝妙的主意。当你向他们提出这个建议时，他们有没有疯狂？好吧，我觉得我好像不得不说服他们一点……什么？事情是这样的。
Greg said, I don't think we'll ever be able to write anything that would satisfy everybody's imagination of this note after all these years. Like the beauty of the note is that as the audience member, you've written the perfect thing on the note. That's brilliant. I mean, he's so smart. Right? That is a very smart take. But it's enough for me to just see it. Well, that was the thing.
格雷格说，我不认为我们写出的任何东西，在经历了这么多年之后，能满足每个人对这张纸条的想象。就像这张纸条的美妙之处在于，作为观众，你自己已经在纸条上写下了最完美的内容。太绝了。我的意思是，他太聪明了。对吧？这是一个非常明智的看法。但对我来说，只要看到它就足够了。好吧，事情就是这样。
We didn't have to read it to you. You just needed the satisfaction of Pam getting it. She finally gets it. Of Pam reading it. Yes. And then you still get to fill in the blank, but you get that closure. I've told this story before too, but John Krasinski wrote the note.
我们不需要读给你听。你只需要帕姆得到它时的那种满足感。她终于得到了。帕姆读着它。是的。然后你仍然可以自己填空，但你得到了那种闭环。我也讲过这个故事，但约翰·卡拉辛斯基写了那张便条。
It was a private note. That he wrote to you as Jenna. Correct. About being your scene partner all those years. Yes. So it was kind of like a goodbye thank you note. I still have it. It's private. I'll never reveal what was in it, but it was a beautiful, beautiful note from one scene partner to another. It made me cry. So when you see me crying in the episode, those are my real tears. I did notice when you were reading it, it seemed like some genuine surprise that you
那是一张私人便条。他作为珍娜写给你的。没错。是关于这些年作为你的搭档。是的。所以这有点像是一封告别感谢信。我至今还留着。这是私人的。我永远不会透露里面写了什么，但这真的是一个场景搭档写给另一个场景搭档的美好字条。它让我哭了。所以当你在剧集里看到我哭的时候，那都是我的真眼泪。我确实注意到你在读它的时候，似乎带着一些真诚的惊讶，你
didn't know what was going to be given to you. Yes, they told me they were going to let John write the note, but I thought he was going to write it as Jim to Pam. So as I'm reading it and I'm realizing that it says, Dear Jenna. Yeah. And then it's just this beautiful letter about what it has meant for us to work together and be these scene partners and, you know,
不知道会给你写些什么。是的，他们告诉我他们会让约翰写这张便条，但我以为他会以吉姆对帕姆的身份来写。所以当我读到它并且意识到上面写着，亲爱的珍娜。是的。然后这只是一封非常美好的信，关于对我们来说一起工作并成为这样的搭档意味着什么，你知道的，
it's like to be Jim and Pam, you know? Yeah, yeah. I was like, oh my gosh, oh, oh my goodness. Yeah, you see, your face goes. I was like, oh my gosh. Oh, oh my goodness. Yeah, you see it. Your face goes through a bunch of realizations. Yeah. And I think you can see John watching me read it. Yes.
就像成为吉姆和帕姆一样，你知道吗？是的，是的。我当时就想，哦天哪，哦，哦天哪。是的，你看，你的表情经历了。我当时就想，哦天哪。哦，哦天哪。是的，你看到了。你的表情经历了一连串的恍然大悟。是的。我想你能看到约翰看着我读信。是的。
I think you see him for sure. Like, OK, I'm standing here as she reads this letter. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I agree with Greg. I'm glad you've never shared what you actually read, what was from John to you, because I don't want to break that fourth wall. I want to imagine this moment between Jim and Pam, and I want to imagine what I would have wanted Jim to say.
我想你绝对能看到他。就像是，好吧，我就站在这里看着她读这封信。嗯。是的，好吧，我同意格雷格的看法。我很高兴你从来没有分享过你实际读到的是什么，也就是约翰写给你的内容，因为我不想打破第四堵墙。我想象吉姆和帕姆之间的这个时刻，我想象我会希望吉姆说些什么。
Mm-hmm. Well, as a wrap gift at the finale, I wanted to return the favor. So I bought a little teapot and I wrote a note to John from Jenna, my own little teapot note to him, thanking him for all those years working together and what it had meant to me. I mean, I'll never have a scene partner like that again. I feel like I have a work partner and a creative partner like that again. I feel like I have a work partner and a creative partner like that here with you, Angela. This is like another moment of like chemistry that you just, you can't plan for it.
嗯哼。好吧，作为大结局的杀青礼物，我想投桃报李。所以我买了一个小茶壶，写了一张约翰收到的便条，是以珍娜的名义，我自己的小茶壶便条给他，感谢他这些年来在一起工作以及这对我的意义。我的意思是，我再也不会有这样的场景搭档了。我觉得我在这里又有了这样一个工作伙伴和创意伙伴，安吉拉。这就像是那种你简直无法刻意安排的化学反应的另一个时刻。
It's just like, it's perfect. But to go on a nine year journey with another actor in such an intimate and vulnerable way as our characters do. It's pretty special. I mean, we're bonded for life for sure. For sure. It's nine years. Yeah, I feel the same way. And you know, we reached out to Dave about this episode and he shared something about this scene about how they would cut from Jim and Dwight back to Pam.
它就像是，太完美了。但能与其他演员以如此亲密和脆弱的方式进行长达九年的旅程，就像我们的角色所做的那样。这真的很特别。我的意思是，我们绝对是一生绑定的。绝对的。那是九年。是的，我有同感。你知道的，我们为这一集联系了戴夫，他分享了关于这个场景的一些事情，关于他们如何从吉姆和德怀特剪辑回到帕姆。
And it's something he fought for. And that was to keep the music playing under the cutaways. And at first I guess Greg wanted to take it out whenever they cut to Jim and Dwight but Claire agreed with Dave and they said it would be a great tool that the documentary filmmakers could use to underscore these two moments and he really felt like it tied the two scenes together and ultimately Greg agreed and they kept the music throughout both scenes. And I do think it tied them together. Beautifully. So there's one more thing about this scene that caused quite a stir after it aired. And it all has to do with a little mistake that they made. You know that very first slide of the little slideshow where Jim has written a note to Pam?
这是他争取来的。那就是在切镜头时让音乐一直播放下去。起劲我猜格雷格想在每次切到吉姆和德怀特时把它去掉，但克莱尔同意戴夫的看法，他们说这将是纪录片制作人用来衬托这两个时刻的一个绝佳工具，他真的觉得这把两个场景联系在了一起，最终格雷格同意了，他们在整个两个场景中都保留了音乐。而且我确实觉得它把它们联系在了一起。非常完美。所以关于这个场景还有一件事，在播出后引起了不小的轰动。这全都是因为他们犯的一个小错误。你知道幻灯片的第一张吗，吉姆给帕姆写了一张便条？
Yes, he wrote, Beasley, you think I'll have regrets. I asked the doc crew to help me show you why I want dot dot dot. Mm hmm. Well, when this episode first aired, Pam's last name was misspelled. It was spelled B E E S L E Y. But that's not how you spell Beasley. You spell it B-E-E-S-L-Y. No E. No E. And fans were like, Jim misspelled his wife's name in the love tribute video? But then people started arguing over what is the correct spelling of Pam's last name. There's been several versions online. Well, here's what I can tell you. In the
是的，他写道，比斯利，你觉得我会后悔吗。我请纪录片摄制组帮我向你展示我为什么想要点点点。嗯哼。好吧，当这一集首次播出时，帕姆的姓氏拼错了。拼成了 B E E S L E Y。但比斯利不是那样拼的。应该拼成 B-E-E-S-L-Y。没有 E。没有 E。粉丝们当时就想，吉姆在爱情致敬视频里把他妻子的名字拼错了？但随后人们开始争论帕姆姓氏的正确拼写是什么。网上有几个版本。好吧，我能告诉你的是，在
very first page of every script, there's a cast list. And from script number one to script finale, Pam's last name has always been spelled B-E-E-S-L-Y. That's how Greg intended it. However, it is misspelled a couple of times in early episodes. And then in this episode. But in business school at her art fair, it's spelled correctly.
每个剧本的第一页，都有一个演员表。从第一集剧本到大结局剧本，帕姆的姓氏一直都是拼作 B-E-E-S-L-Y。这就是格雷格的本意。然而，在早期的剧集中它确实被拼错了几次。然后是在这一集里。但在商学院的艺术展上，它是拼对的。
In the credits for Threat Level Midnight, But in business school at her art fair, it's spelled correctly. In the credits for Threat Level Midnight, it's spelled correctly. On the big poster outside their wedding, where they misspelled Jim's last name, Halpritt, her name is spelled correctly. So that is the correct spelling. You heard it here. You heard it here. And Angela, when you made us those matching blue hoodies, you spelled it correctly.
在《午夜威胁级别》的职员表里，但在商学院的艺术展上，它是拼对的。在《午夜威胁级别》的职员表里，它是拼对的。在他们婚礼外面那个拼错吉姆姓氏哈尔普里特（Halpritt）的大海报上，她的名字拼写是正确的。所以那是正确的拼写。你们在这里听到了。你们在这里听到了。安吉拉，当你给我们做那些配套的蓝色连帽衫时，你拼对了。
I did. So I have a hoodie with Beasley on the back. I don't know how this happened exactly, but it has been corrected. So they corrected it for the DVDs, they corrected it for syndication, but on the first viewing it was spelled wrong. But you know, there were some people who tried to justify it by saying, hey, Jim didn't make the video, the doc crew made the video. The doc crew didn't know how to spell her last name. But also, doesn't inspire a lot of confidence in the doc crew. To get everything right.
我确实拼对了。所以我有一件背面写着比斯利的连帽衫。我不知道这具体是怎么发生的，但它已经得到了纠正。所以他们在DVD中纠正了它，在联合播出中纠正了它，但在第一次观看时它确实拼错了。不过你知道，有些人试图为之辩解，说，嘿，视频不是吉姆制作的，是纪录片摄制组制作的。纪录片摄制组不知道怎么拼她的姓。但是话说回来，这也让人对纪录片摄制组没法产生太多信心。能把所有事情都做好。
I mean, literally what they're supposed to do is just document. Well let's move to the bullpen because Erin is cueing up the music. There are disco lights. It is time to dance. And I thought you might like a breakdown of this dance sequence. Please. When the music starts, the kitchen door opens and Darryl is standing with his back to the bullpen and a leather jacket with his collar up. He spins around.
我的意思是，他们字面上的本职工作就是记录。好吧，让我们转到办公区，因为艾琳正在播放音乐。有迪斯科灯光。是时候跳舞了。我想你可能会喜欢这个舞蹈段落的分解。请。当音乐响起时，厨房门打开了，达里尔背对着办公区站着，穿着皮夹克，领子立着。他转过身来。
His first dance move is with Stanley. They do a series of handshakes and then chest bump. Then Daryl and Nellie have a very sexy dance. I was like, that's a couple I hadn't thought of before. Okay. Then Daryl and Toby do a dance where, what are they doing? Are they pretending to ride a pony? Are they pretending to rope a cow?
他的第一个舞步是和斯坦利一起。他们做了一系列握手动作，然后碰胸。然后达里尔和内莉跳了一支非常性感的舞。我当时就想，这是一对之前我没想过的组合。好吧。然后达里尔和托比跳了一支舞，他们在做什么？他们在假装骑小马吗？他们在假装套牛吗？
It's like the last... Yeah. Are they lassoing one another? One another? I don't know. Then Daryl and Phyllis do a really fancy choreographed kickball change spin, then a dip move. Phyllis was having fun in real life in that moment. For sure. All of her dancing days coming back.
就像最后...是的。他们在用套索套对方吗？套对方？我不知道。然后达里尔和菲利斯跳了一个非常华丽的编排好的踢球换步旋转，然后是一个下腰动作。那一刻菲利斯在现实生活中玩得很开心。绝对的。她所有的舞蹈岁月都回来了。
Then Daryl does air guitar with Creed. And then with Meredith, Daryl doesn't really dance, but Meredith waves her hand over his crotch and then spanks his butt. And then at 17 minutes and 23 seconds is my favorite. It is Darryl, Kevin, and Oscar. They're doing a very Madonna vogue kind of dance moment. It is epic. Then Pam and Jim and Darryl and Aaron form a line and dance
然后达里尔和克里德一起弹空气吉他。然后和梅雷迪思一起，达里尔其实没怎么跳舞，但梅雷迪思把手从他的裆部挥过，然后拍了他的屁股。接着在17分23秒是我最喜欢的。那是达里尔、凯文和奥斯卡。他们跳了一种非常麦当娜式的时尚杂志（vogue）舞蹈动作。太史诗了。然后帕姆、吉姆、达里尔和艾琳排成一排跳舞
kind of like a I don't know what that was a Congo line kind of thing kind of and then it ends with Daryl and Aaron spinning in a circle holding hands in front of reception. We got a lot of fan questions about this. People wanted to know if music was really playing or if we had to do that thing where you're dancing to silence. No yeah. Music was really playing or if we had to do that thing where you're dancing to silence. Oh, yeah. Music was really playing. It was playing low, but we had it so that we could dance to the beat. But there were two rehearsals for this. Our resident choreographer, Mary Ann Kellogg, came in and she worked with each person on what their dance with Darryl might be. So that was all planned.
有点像...我不知道那是什么，康加舞队那种东西，然后以达里尔和艾琳在前台前面牵着手转圈结束。我们收到了很多关于这部分的粉丝提问。人们想知道音乐是真的在播放，还是我们不得不假装在寂寞中跳舞。不，是的。音乐是真的在播放吗，还是我们必须做那种在寂寞中跳舞的事情。哦，是的。音乐真的在播放。声音放得很低，但我们能听到，以便随着节拍跳舞。不过为此排练了两次。我们的驻场编舞玛丽安·凯洛格来了，她和每个人都探讨了他们与达里尔的舞蹈会是怎样的。所以这些都是计划好的。
It wasn't like we just did impromptu moves or anything. Dave said it was actually a fairly complicated scene. It had to be carefully choreographed with camera and with Darryl's movement through the office. He wanted to make sure that everyone was in focus and had their moment. We had a fan catch that I know about from personal experience. It was Kelly Y. from Carver, Massachusetts, who said,
这并不是说我们只是做了即兴动作什么的。戴夫说这实际上是一个相当复杂的场景。它必须与摄像机以及达里尔在办公室里的移动进行仔细的编排。他想确保每个人都在焦点内并且有他们的的高光时刻。我们有一个我从个人经验中知道的粉丝捕捉到的细节。那是来自马萨诸塞州卡弗的凯利·Y，她说，
I have been waiting nine seasons to tell you this background catch that I notice every time I watch this episode. At 17 minutes and 45 seconds, when Jim and Pam are dancing in the background, you can very clearly see John mess up his dance move and mouth the words, Oh, shit. Kelly said this makes me crack up every time. Kelly, John and I were added to this dance scene at the very last minute. I don't know why, but we had not been at the other rehearsals.
我等了九季来告诉你这个背景彩蛋，我每次看这一集都能注意到。在17分45秒时，当吉姆和帕姆在背景中跳舞时，你能非常清楚地看到约翰把舞步跳砸了，并且口型说出了，哦，靠。凯利说这每次都让我爆笑。凯利，我和约翰是在最后一分钟才被加入到这个舞蹈场景中的。我不知道为什么，但我们没有参加其他的排练。
And so on the day we got our dance moves and we were so clumsy and we kept messing up and we were cracking ourselves up because we were like, why can't we do this simple dance move? because we were like, why can't we do this simple dance move? But this is just such a wonderfully joyous moment in this finale before the finale. And Darryl has a talking head where he says, you know, leaving quietly seemed dignified, but having Kevin grind up on his front while Aaron pretended to hump him from behind is a more accurate tribute to his years there.
所以在当天我们拿到了舞步，我们非常笨拙，一直出错，我们自己都笑疯了，因为我们当时想，为什么我们做不好这个简单的舞步？因为我们当时想，为什么我们做不好这个简单的舞步？但这只是大结局之前这一集里一个非常欢乐美妙的时刻。达里尔有一个单人采访镜头，他说，你知道的，悄悄离开显得很有尊严，但让凯文在他身前磨蹭，而艾琳在背后假装对他做出骑乘动作，是对他这些年岁月的更准确的致敬。
He said he's really going to miss these guys. Well, now everyone's leaving for the day and they say, we'll see you at Poor Richards. Because remember, everybody's going to gather at Poor Richards because the documentary is airing tonight. Oscar says, I'll drop Philip off at my mother's. I love that Oscar's mother is Philip's babysitter. I know. How cute. And he says, Angela, you can't come with me
他说他真的很想念这些家伙。好吧，现在大家都要离开去过一天了，他们说，我们在穷理查酒吧见吧。因为记住，每个人都要聚集在穷理查酒吧，因为纪录片今晚播出。奥斯卡说，我要把菲利普送到我妈妈那儿。我喜欢奥斯卡的妈妈是菲利普的保姆这一点。我懂。多可爱啊。然后他说，安吉拉，你不能跟我一起去
because I don't want my mother to know I'm living with a straight woman and get her hopes up. Yeah. So Angela is going to drive to poor Richard's by herself. But oh, boy, Dwight comes out of nowhere. He's got a siren on top of his car and a bullhorn and he's shouting at her to pull over. Well, I have a lot to say about the scene.
因为我不想让我妈知道我跟一个直女住在一起，然后又让她燃起希望。对。所以安吉拉要一个人开车去穷理查酒吧。但是，天哪，德怀特突然不知道从哪儿冒出来了。他的车顶上安了警报器，还拿着一个扩音器，大喊着让她靠边停车。好吧，关于这场戏我有很多话要说。
We wanted it to feel as real as possible. Okay, well, we have a fan question from Rachel S. in Shetland, Scotland, who wanted to know, how did you do this driving scene and pulling over? Because I think that's you in the car, Angela. Am I right? It looks like you. You are correct. So we did a combination, and I have a lot of pictures from this particular scene. I brought my camera to set that day. And also Steve Burgess took a bunch of pictures. We did a combination of my car being pulled where I'm not driving.
我们希望它尽可能显得真实。好吧，我们有一个来自苏格兰设德兰的粉丝瑞秋·S. 的提问，她想知道，这场开车和靠边停车的戏是怎么拍的？因为我觉得车里的人就是你，安吉拉。我没说错吧？看起来就是你。你猜得没错。所以我们结合了多种方式，我有很多这场戏的特定照片。那天我带了相机去片场。而且史蒂夫·伯杰斯也拍了一堆照片。我们结合了由别的车牵引我的车、而我并不在驾驶的情况。
That's in the straightaways. And then where we pull off the road is really me. That's what I thought. Yes, that's really me. When he cuts you off and kind of forces your car off the road. Right. Because we had it. It had to be us because I get out of the car so quickly.
那是在直道上。然后我们在路边停下的那部分真的是我在开。我就觉得是这样。是的，真的是我在开。当他把你逼停并有点迫使你的车开出路面时。对。因为我们需要这样。必须是我们，因为我要很快地下车。
And they had cameras everywhere. They had cameras mounted to the car. They had lipstick cameras inside so they could catch a bunch of different angles. And then we also did have stunt drivers for when the cars were going really fast on the straightaway. Okay. Okay.
而且他们到处都架了摄像机。他们在车上安装了摄像机。里面装了微型摄像机，这样他们就能捕捉到许多不同的角度。然后，当汽车在直道上开得非常快时，我们确实也用了特技演员。好吧。好吧。
Well, when you get out of that car, Angela, talk about coming in hot. Well. You are pissed. I'm pissed. I just got run off the road. I mean you'd be pissed off. Yeah. So here's the thing, when we did the first take of this it just felt a little stiff, right? And Dave and Brent were like, you guys, why don't you at the beginning improvise to get into the main beat of the scene, to the proposal? So we were like, okay. So I thought I would play you the scene
好了，当你下车的时候，安吉拉，那可真叫气势汹汹啊。好吧。你气炸了。我气炸了。我刚被人逼得冲出路面。我是说换谁都会气炸的。对。所以是这样的，当我们拍这场戏的第一条时，感觉有点僵硬，对吧？然后戴夫和布伦特就说，你们俩，为什么不从一开始就即兴发挥，进入这场戏的核心节奏，也就是求婚呢？所以我们就想，好吧。我想把这场戏放给你们听
and then I'll tell you the parts that were improvised. Okay, great. Pull over! What? Move to the side of the road! Why? Pull over! Why? Move over! What is...Dwight!
然后我再告诉你们哪些部分是即兴发挥的。太好了。靠边停车！什么？靠路边停下！为什么？靠边停车！为什么？靠过去！这到底是……德怀特！
Dwight, what the f*** is your problem? Sons, woman! Who drives like that? I love you! And I don't care that Phillips is not my son. I will raise a hundred children! With a hundred of your lovers if it means I can be with you. Can you put that down?
德怀特，你他妈的有什么毛病？闭嘴，女人！谁是这样开车的？我爱你！而且我不在乎菲利普是不是我的儿子。我要抚养一百个孩子！只要能跟你在一起，哪怕是一百个你的情人生的。你能把那个放下吗？
This expresses how loudly I love you. It's too loud. This is a ring taken from the buttocks of my grandmother, put there by the gangster patriarch of the Khor's dynasty, melted in a foundry run by Mennonites. Okay, yes, yes, I will! Yeah! I love you.
这表达了我爱你的声音有多大。声音太大了。这是一枚从我祖母的屁股上取下来的戒指，是被科尔家族的黑帮大家长塞进去的，并在门诺派教徒经营的铸造厂里熔化过。好吧，好，我愿意！耶！我爱你。
I love you! And I lied to you. What? Philip's your son. What? Why would you say that? I just needed you to want to marry me because you wanted to marry me. Get out! I'm a dad! You're a dad!
我爱你！我跟你撒谎了。什么？菲利普是你的儿子。什么？你为什么这么说？我只是需要你想娶我，是因为你想娶我。滚！我是个爸爸！你是个爸爸！
Ha ha ha ha ha! Oh, it's so good. It's so fun to rewatch that, I have to tell you guys. We really, man, we put our hearts out there for that scene. So the parts that are improvised are Dwight, what the f*** is your problem? Yes. And then him saying, shut up, woman.
哈哈哈哈哈！哦，太棒了。重看那一幕真的太有趣了，我得告诉你们。为了那场戏，我们真的是把心都掏出来了。所以即兴发挥的部分是：德怀特，你他妈的有什么毛病？没错。然后他说，闭嘴，女人。
Okay. And then me saying, who drives like that? And him saying, listen to me. Then we start the scripted part with, I love you. And I don't care that Philip's not my son. I improvised, can you put that down? And it's too loud. And then Rain rift off a scripted line about
好的。接着我说，谁是这样开车的？然后他说，听我说。接下来我们开始按剧本演，台词是，我爱你。我不在乎菲利普是不是我的儿子。我即兴发挥了“你能把那个放下吗？”和“声音太大了”。然后雷恩脱离了剧本台词，说了一句
that's how he expresses his love. And then after Angela says she will marry him, we kissed. And I said, I love you. And that wasn't scripted. And Dwight said, I love you. And that wasn't scripted. And Dwight said, I love you. And then we went into the beat where I shared with him that I had lied to him. And the scene was supposed to end with Dwight just saying, get out. But then Rain improvised, I'm a dad. And I said, you're a dad. And then we kissed again.
那是他表达爱的方式。然后安吉拉答应嫁给他之后，我们接吻了。我说，我爱你。这不是剧本里的。德怀特说，我爱你。这也是剧本里没有的。德怀特说，我爱你。然后我们进入了那个节奏，我向他坦白我对他撒了谎。这场戏本来应该在德怀特说“滚”的时候结束。但雷恩即兴加了一句“我是个爸爸”。我说，“你是个爸爸”。然后我们又吻了一下。
So Angela, we did get a fan mail flurry here. People really want to know, how do you or the writers justify the fact that this DNA test said that Dwight was not the father? People want to know, did Angela pay them off? Did Dwight take the wrong diaper? There were a lot of babies at the family portrait studio. Tell us what you think.
所以安吉拉，我们确实收到了雪片般的粉丝来信。大家真的很想知道，你或编剧们怎么解释这个DNA测试结果说德怀特不是亲生父亲的事实？大家想知道，安吉拉是不是贿赂了他们？是不是德怀特拿错了尿布？家庭全家福照相馆里有很多婴儿。告诉我们你们是怎么想的。
Well, I understand the fan mail flurry over this because it was set up that it might not be Dwight's child, right? Very clearly. This is how I always made it make sense for me. When Dwight takes the diaper, Angela doesn't know if he got Phillips or not. She goes with him. She's very invested. This could end her marriage. And although she loved Dwight, she thought it was over for them. They had missed their moment. And she had built this whole life with the state senator, for better or for worse.
好吧，我理解大家对此雪片般的粉丝来信，因为剧情设定这可能不是德怀特的骨肉，对吧？非常明确。我是这样让自己想通这一切的。当德怀特拿走尿布时，安吉拉并不知道他有没有拿到菲利普的。她跟着他去了。她对此深陷其中。这可能会毁了她的婚姻。尽管她爱德怀特，但她以为他们之间彻底结束了。他们错过了那个时机。而且她已经和州参议员建立起了整个人生，无论好坏。
So she sat there with him and waited for the results. And they held hands because I think it was as big for her as it was for him. She didn't know if he was going to find out the truth that she knew all along. Okay. And she didn't say anything because she wasn't ready to tell him. And then when they said, it's not your child, she is relieved because now she can keep her life intact. And there's a lot of sadness for her as well. But what you're saying is that, and you've said this before,
所以她坐在他身边等待结果。他们手拉着手，因为我觉得这对她来说和对他的意义一样重大。她不知道他是否会发现她一直都知道的真相。好吧。而且她什么也没说，因为她还没准备好告诉他。然后当他们说，这不是你的孩子时，她松了一口气，因为现在她的生活可以保持完整了。同时她也感到非常悲伤。但你的意思是，而且你以前也说过，
that she never really consummated her relationship with the senator. The only person she was sexually active with was Dwight. This was Dwight's baby. But somehow, something sort of serendipitously happened in the testing. But somehow something went wrong in the testing facility or maybe he grabbed the wrong diaper and that's why the test result said that. I think he grabbed the wrong diaper. There were a lot of babies there that day. I think
她其实从来没有和参议员发生过性关系。她唯一有过性行为的人只有德怀特。这就是德怀特的宝宝。但不知为什么，检测过程中发生了一些奇妙的事情。但不知为什么检测机构出了差错，或者他拿错了尿布，所以测试结果才会那样。我觉得他拿错了尿布。那天那里有很多婴儿。我觉得
he grabbed the wrong diaper, but Angela couldn't be sure, and that's why she followed him there. And then I think there were many times she wanted to tell him, but she thought he had moved on. And then I think she didn't know how to tell him. I just wanted to add one final thing about this scene that I will never forget. After we did the take that we knew was the one. You know, we were both crying. Rain and I were both tearing up.
他拿错了尿布，但安吉拉不能确定，这就是她跟着他去那里的原因。然后我觉得有很多次她想告诉他，但她以为他已经向前看了。后来我觉得她不知道该怎么告诉他。我只想补充关于这场戏的最后一点，我永远不会忘记。在我们拍完那条我们知道就是它了的镜头之后。你知道，我们都哭了。雷恩和我都在飙泪。
Dave yelled cut. And I looked over to our first assistant camera operator, Chris Workman, and he was wiping tears away from his eyes. And it just made me so happy. You know, our crew was rooting for this couple. Rain and I were rooting for this couple. And I asked Brent Forrester, our writer, what it was like to write this proposal scene. And here's what he had to say.
戴夫喊了卡。我看向我们的第一摄影助理克里斯·沃克曼，他正在擦拭眼角的泪水。这让我太开心了。你知道的，我们的剧组在支持这对情侣。雷恩和我都在支持这对情侣。我问我们的编剧布伦特·福斯特，写这场求婚戏是什么感觉。他是这样说的。
There were moments on the office where it seemed like something sacred had happened on set. Jim and Pam getting married at Niagara was a moment like that where everyone who was there seemed like they had been transformed by seeing it live. And another moment like that was Dwight proposing to Angela in the second to last episode. We knew in the writer's room that we had created something clever with Angela's lie to Dwight, but we didn't know how it would play
在《办公室》里有些时刻，感觉片场好像发生了某种神圣的事情。吉姆和帕姆在尼亚加拉大瀑布结婚就是一个那样的时刻，当时在场的每个人似乎都被亲眼目睹这一幕给改变了。另一个那样的时刻就是德怀特倒数第二集向安吉拉求婚。我们在编剧室里就知道，我们通过安吉拉对德怀特谎言创造了一些很聪明的东西，但我们不知道它会呈现出什么效果
until the actors showed up on set. Well, Angela Kinsey and Rainn Wilson had been playing these characters for nine seasons and there was so much real emotion pent up. When Dwight proposed to her and she accepted there was this feeling of joy on set and then she reveals that he's also a father. Now Rainn Wilson is a father and the joy of that moment seemed to hit him by surprise and it rippled through him and Angela and the whole set. The director called cut and everyone just looked at each other with these gentle smiles on their faces like they had seen something sacred.
直到演员们出现在片场。好吧，安吉拉·金西和雷恩·威尔逊已经饰演这些角色九季了，里面积压了太多的真实情感。当德怀特向她求婚而她接受时，片场有一种喜悦的感觉，然后她透露他也是个父亲。现在雷恩·威尔逊当爸爸了，那一刻的喜悦似乎出乎意料地击中了她，并在他、安吉拉以及整个剧组中激荡开来。导演喊了卡，大家只是带着温柔的微笑看着彼此，就像他们看到了什么神圣的东西一样。
The writers set it up, the actors bring it to life. And when the actors bring to life real sacred emotions of joy and love, I think that's the highest that our art form can achieve. No, that's beautiful. I know. Yeah, what a wonderful thing to say, Brent, thank you. Well, I know there's something crazy
编剧们搭好了台子，演员们赋予了它生命。当演员们将喜悦和爱的真实神圣情感赋予生命时，我认为那是我们的艺术形式所能达到的最高境界。不，这太美妙了。我知道。是的，多棒的一番话啊，布伦特，谢谢你。好吧，我知道有一件疯狂的事
about this day of shooting. This must have been very emotional for you, Angela, because this day of shooting started with this scene, this proposal scene. Then y'all broke for lunch, and we read the finale. We had a giant table read. With hundreds of people. Yeah, so you went from that to the final table read. To then all of us being together at Poor Richards
关于拍摄这一天。对你来说这一定非常情绪化，安吉拉，因为拍摄这一天是从这场戏开始的，这场求婚戏。然后你们午休，接着我们读了最后一集的剧本。我们进行了一次盛大的剧本围读。有几百人。对，所以你从那直接过渡到了最后的剧本围读。然后我们所有人一起聚在穷理查酒吧
to watch the beginning of the documentary airing. Yes. I was a hot mess all day. Sure. I cried off and on all day. I remember being so tired that night, just emotionally so tired. I have pictures, Jenna, of you and I walking in together to that final table read. Holding hands.
观看纪录片播出的开头。是的。我整天都是一团糟。确实。我整天都在断断续续地哭。我记得那天晚上我累坏了，情绪上真的累坏了。我还有照片，珍娜，是你和我一起走进去参加最后那场剧本围读的。手拉着手。
Holding hands. We were so, oh man, just overwhelmed by the moment. And we walked in together holding hands. Mm-hmm. Next week, I'm going to play an audio clip of Greg's speech to us before we read that final episode. It's really beautiful. Mm-hmm. But I mention all that because when we go to this next scene where we're all gathered at Poor Richards as a group and we're going to watch the documentary, all of us are coming off of that very emotional table read. And I'll just never forget sitting in that group scene together. It was kind of perfect. It really created that moment
手拉着手。我们当时太，天哪，简直被那一刻淹没了。我们手拉着手走了进去。嗯。下周，我要放一段音频剪辑，那是格雷格在我们宣读最后一集之前对我们说的话。真的很美。嗯。但我提到这一切是因为当我们走到下一场戏时，我们大家作为一个群体聚集在穷理查酒吧，我们要观看纪录片，我们所有人都刚经历完那场情绪激动的剧本围读。我永远不会忘记一起坐在那场群戏里。感觉简直太完美了。它真的营造了那种时刻
in us. And I have a picture of you and me and John and Rain from the bar. Yeah. Sitting there. Yeah. It's one of my favorites. So here's what happens. Angela and Dwight arrive to Poor Richards, but the bartender is refusing to put the documentary on because there is a college baseball game on. Can I give the bartender a shout out?
在我们心中。我有一张你、我和约翰还有雷恩在酒吧的合照。对。坐在那儿。对。这是我最喜欢的照片之一。事情是这样的。安吉拉和德怀特到达了穷理查酒吧，但酒保拒绝播放纪录片，因为正在播一场大学棒球比赛。我可以对酒保大喊一声致敬吗？
Please do. The bartender is played by Scott Robinson. He is a longtime friend of Kate Flannery and I. He is an amazing improviser and performer. In fact, he and Kate had a hilarious lounge act they did for years. Oh, it's so good. So good. It's called the Lampshades.
请便。酒保由斯科特·罗宾逊饰演。他是凯特·弗兰内里和我多年的老朋友。他是一个了不起的即兴演员和表演者。事实上，他和凯特曾有一个非常搞笑的休息室表演，他们做了多年。哦，太棒了。太棒了。它叫“灯罩乐队”。
It was described as America's favorite Dying Lounge Act. They even at one point had their own single called Out of Space. She packed my bags last night, pre-flight. Flight. Zero hour, 9am. M. Zero hour, 9 a.m. M. I'm gonna be high as a kite by then, by then, by then, by then, by then. This show is so funny.
它被描述为美国最受欢迎的垂死休息室表演。他们甚至一度有自己的单曲，叫做《太空之外》。她昨晚帮我收拾了行李，在飞行前。飞行。零点，上午9点。M. 零点，上午9点。M. 到时候我就会像风筝一样飘得高高的，到时候，到时候，到时候，到时候。这个节目太搞笑了。
I saw it two times, maybe three times. I can't get enough of it. Kate would wear this jumpsuit, this crazy wig, and she would do this like full squat, and then deep squat, and then pop up and do a high kick. It was incredible, very athletic. And a red romper. Yep.
我看了两遍，也许三遍。我看不够。凯特会穿着这件连体裤，戴着这个疯狂的假发，然后她会做一个完全下蹲，然后深蹲，然后蹦起来做一个高踢腿。太不可思议了，非常具有运动感。还有一件红色的连衣裤。是的。
And Scott was such the perfect scene partner in the lampshades, his character's hilarious. I mean, it's what you imagine, just like slick back hair, like pencil mustache and his little cigarette. Cigarette hanging out the corner of his mouth the entire show. Yeah. So this episode is going to end with Andy entering,
斯科特在“灯罩乐队”里是个绝佳的搭档，他的角色太搞笑了。我是说，那就是你能想象到的，头发向后梳得油亮，留着铅笔胡子，叼着小烟。烟一直挂在嘴角，整场演出都是如此。是的。所以这一集将以安迪的登场结束，
which was so great to have Ed Helms back with us in this big group scene. And he's going to be the tie-breaking vote that's going to get the bartender to switch it from baseball to the documentary. And it begins. Yeah. And it begins with the first few lines of the pilot. We had a fan question from Amy A. in Pasadena, California who asked were we actually watching something or was that audio added in post? No, Amy, we were actually watching it. Dave put together a short video.
埃德·海尔姆斯能回到我们身边参与这场盛大的群戏真是太棒了。他将投下打破僵局的一票，让酒保把频道从棒球切换到纪录片。开始了。对。它以试播集的前几台词开始。我们收到了来自加州帕萨迪纳的艾米·A. 的一个粉丝提问，她问我们当时是真的在看什么节目，还是音频是后期添加的？不，艾米，我们当时真的在看。戴夫剪辑了一段短视频。
So you saw the logo that came on before the documentary. He said, if you look closely at the names and the end credits from like the previous show, he put his nephews, Jayden and Owen on there. So sweet. But we were really watching that first scene of Jim and Michael's office. And it was really sentimental. Yeah. That is AARM, part two, everyone. I can't believe it. I want to give a big thank you to Santi Gold, Steve Burgess, Brent Forrester, Dave Rogers, Jessica Sinclair, and now next week is the finale. Guys, before we go. Oh, before we go.
所以你看到了纪录片播出前出现的标志。他说，如果你仔细看上一集的名字和片尾字幕，他把他的外甥杰登和欧文的名字放上去了。太贴心了。但我们当时真的在看吉姆和迈克尔办公室的那第一场戏。真的很感伤。是的，各位，那是《AARM》第二部分。我真不敢相信。我要对桑蒂·古德、史蒂夫·伯杰斯、布伦特·福斯特、戴夫·罗杰斯、杰西卡·辛克莱表示衷心的感谢，接下来下周就是大结局了。大家，在我们离开之前。哦，在我们离开之前。
Brian Selengo or Selenjo sent in a song he wrote about the podcast. I think it's very sweet. Oh. podcast I think it's very sweet. Oh. On every tangent, tidbit and tell all The ladies who were there got to walk us through it all Like the times that we went behind the scenes To see just how you planned it Like the wedding in Niagara Or the failure to save Bandit
布莱恩·塞伦戈或塞伦霍发来了一首他写的关于这个播客的歌。我觉得非常贴心。哦。播客，我觉得非常贴心。哦。在每一个题外话、花絮和爆料中 那些曾经到场的女士们带我们重温了这一切 就像我们幕后的那些时光 去看看你们是如何筹划的 比如尼亚加拉大瀑布的婚礼 或者未能拯救班迪特的失败
Deep dives and fast facts All the office content you'd ever want in a podcast Birthdays and interviews And oh my god how perfect is Keanu We've learned a million things along the way Like the undisputed genius of the late, great Phil Shea And all the candy bag lines that made us laugh And all the little stories that were in the shooting draft
深度挖掘与快讯 你在播客中想要的所有办公室内容 生日和采访 还有哦天哪基努怎么能这么完美 我们一路上学到了无数的事情 比如已故伟大的菲尔·谢伊无可争议的天才 还有所有让我们欢笑的糖果袋台词 还有拍摄剧本里的那些小故事
The purchasing of music rights right down to the penny And how the hell did Steve Carell never win an Emmy? Deep dives and fast fads All the office content you'd ever want in a podcast Birthdays and interviews and oh my god how dreamy is Keanu It all seems so very arbitrary I started this job at a podcast network because they were hiring I took a desk behind an old shower curtain because it was empty
音乐版权的购买精确到每一分钱 史蒂夫·卡瑞尔到底怎么会从来没赢过艾美奖？ 深度挖掘与快讯 你在播客中想要的所有办公室内容 生日和采访还有哦天哪基努是多么梦幻 这一切看起来都那么随意 我在播客网络开始这份工作是因为他们在招人 我在一张旧浴帘后面占了一个办公桌，因为它是空的
but no matter how you get there or where you end up human beings have this miraculous gift of making that place their home. A podcast is such an ordinary thing, but there's a lot of beauty in ordinary things. Isn't that kind of the point? It seems this rewatch podcast has come into an end But every office fan knows we can just listen again To the deep dives and the fast facts
但不管你是怎么来到那里的，或者最终到了哪里，人类都有着一种神奇的天赋，能把那个地方变成他们的家。播客是一件多么普通的事啊，但在普通的事物中蕴含着许多美。这不正是重点所在吗？看起来这个重播播客就要结束了 但每个办公室粉丝都知道我们可以再听一遍 那些深度挖掘和快讯
All the office content you'd ever want in a podcast than you'd ever want in a podcast birthdays and interviews office ladies by now you know we love you whatever's next you know we'll follow that too Wow, I don't even know what to say. That was so beautiful. So nice. It was so lovely. Well. And I love that Keanu made it in. That was so wonderful.
你在播客中想要的所有办公室内容 甚至比你想要的还要多的办公室内容 生日和采访 办公室女士们，现在你们知道我们爱你们 接下来无论发生什么，你知道我们也会追随到底 哇，我甚至不知道该说些什么。太美妙了。太美好了。真的太可爱了。好吧。而且我很高兴基努出现了。太棒了。
Thank you, Sam, for sharing that with us. Sure. Thank you to Brian for reaching out. Yeah. That was really, really lovely, Brian. Thank you. I know that it would have meant so much to Phil to be in that. So thank you for giving us that too.
谢谢萨姆跟我们分享这个。不客气。谢谢布莱恩的联系。是的，真的很棒，布莱恩。谢谢你。我知道能出现在里面对菲尔来说意义重大。所以也谢谢你带给我们这些。
And we're not going anywhere and we're also going to keep trying to get Keanu on this podcast. So we can't finish this out until we speak to that man. Okay. But we have lots and lots of more Office fun stuff coming your way and we're excited to start sharing about it with you all. Thank you so much. I'm so emotional for this community. You've meant so much to Jen and I. Okay. We'll see you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
我们哪儿也不去，而且我们也会继续努力把基努请到这个播客上来。所以在和那个人对话之前，我们是不会结束的。好吧。但是我们还有许许多多更多的办公室趣事要带给你们，我们很高兴开始与你们大家分享。非常感谢。我为这个社群感到非常激动。你们对珍娜和我意义重大。好吧。我们下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是天狼星电台（SiriusXM）旗下奥德赛（Audyssey）栏目
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。奥德赛的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubberree》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。